yeah
everybody hello hello we're gonna be working on the schedule
before okay actually i should change the screen we're gonna
be working on our schedule before this before uh the actual
stream itself because um the schedule's been really late um
only because i still don't know if i'm participating in the
rivals tournament there's been a lot of back and forth and a
lot of rebalancing like I don't know like I'm I'm so
confused with what the fuck is going on uh so let me add
chat in real quick my chat is still not fixed yet so that's
why it still looks like the it still looks like this it
apparently changed the chat UI so that's why uh that's why
the chat overlays are broken All right, let's see.
I fixed it.
Here we go.
We have to use this temporarily.
No, this moth is gone again.
Moth update.
I was, I changed the, the moth was there this morning, and I
was like, I've had it.
So I had the door open, and I was like, and so when he was
flying around, I was trying to change the course direction
of this moth.
And yeah, I'm just going to make it free.
I'm just going to put free day.
And that's why, the reason why, because they kept saying
like, oh, tomorrow you'll find out.
Tomorrow you'll find out.
And then it's been tomorrow so many times.
But then they were like, today, today would be the day they
finalized and announced the teams.
But apparently, um, I said like, oh, I was like really
worried because like it didn't feel, it was like a bit not
balanced.
And then, um, I was like, I was like, wait a minute, I know
this player, this player does not play this character, nor
do they play DPS.
And, because I know there are one trick of one particular
character.
I was like, why are they in DPS?
I was so confused.
literally have zero they have like 30 minutes on dps and
then 30 plus hours on support but they were in the dps role
so i was like super confused i was like that doesn't make no
sense and why is he considered why is he considered a dps
role and i was like this this she doesn't make sense and it
was like apparently um they're having a balancing issues uh
triple support is real they did made they removed the dps
role and just put another support in there so it was weird
and then apparently i wasn't the only one that was like
saying and i was like this is too confusing and too last
minute i might drop it i might as well i'm just dropping out
There's too many changes because at first I was like, yeah,
I can do it.
And they were changing the stuff, like live while, and I was
looking at the sheet.
And I was like, wait, why are they changing stuff?
Because apparently other people were dropping out too
because it was so last minute.
They're like, oh, shit, I already filled my schedule up.
You know, because like, that's the thing.
There's some people that already have their entire schedule
planned up or like they have like obligation sponsors or
stuff.
So, you know, they couldn't, they don't know.
They're like, oh, I haven't heard anything back yet.
about like whether or not they're gonna be in the tournament
and Obviously it's it's very last-minute and like it's
understandable because there's so many other things going on
and like planning wise They might have had like issues on
there.
They might have like problem like you know They were very
busy and everything and also like balancing is not fun It is
not fun.
It takes a long time to do balancing and stuff and so like
they were like rebalancing everything and if it was like
changing The balancing team cheat was like the teams list
was changing a every like hour or so um because they heard
back whether or not people can participate and then
obviously like people would drop out they have to find new
players to replace them and then they have to rebalance
everything again with the new players that are replacing
them you know it's not fun at all it's not fun so I was just
like like my manager was just like why don't you just make a
decision whether you're not participating or not because
like you know we gotta give them an answer because I to
confirm that I was just like oh I just want to know like um
what the team like how like I just want to know like what
the like what the teams are and who's playing and stuff so I
saw it I was like first I was like yeah that's cool like you
tell which team is gonna it's very strong they're like you
tell which team is gonna be really strong and which are the
weaker teams but you know it's fine like I'm not captain or
anything it's fine um I'm willing to to go into it.
But then, like, the teams kept changing.
So now it's just like, okay, I don't know what's going on
anymore.
Because the teams keep changing.
And I was like, looking up.
And I was like, wait a minute.
This person doesn't even play this role.
Because I think marking by peak rank, marking by peak rank
is, like, harder to balance.
Because, like, the last time they, what if, this rank was a
year ago like you know and like they might be like eternity
like they might be eternity on support but but they are not
the same eternity they're not in the same rank as uh or
celestial even there might be celestial support or eternity
support and if they put them on an off roll they're
technically like might not be they might not be eternity dps
or eternity tank or Celestial Tank or Celestial DPS.
So their rank for that role might be different.
So, yeah, I'm GM in Overwatch nine years ago.
And because, like, apparently another player, thank God, as
I was like, oh, vindication because they were like, I
haven't been Celestial in, like, since, I haven't been
Celestial in X amount of seasons.
Like, I've been, and they were like, I think I'm like this
rank.
So I don't know if I, like, I don't, I think we got to
rebalance.
Like, oh my god, thank god.
I'm not the only one that felt like this seems a little off.
Like, I was like, oh thank god, okay.
At least, like, I'm not the only one that sees, like,
something feels a little off, you know.
So it was, like, very confusing.
So I was just like, to my manager, it was like, you gotta
make a decision.
We can't keep, like, figuring this thing out because I was
just like, I don't know.
They're supposed to announce it today.
And I, like, I don't feel comfortable.
with, like, I don't feel comfortable because I don't know
what's happening for the teams and stuff anymore.
And I would like to know, like, the confirmed team and
whether or not, like, like, how about, like, the balancing
thing.
Because, like, you know, I just want to know right now.
So then they're like, just, then my manager was like, well,
we could just drop out.
So you don't have to worry about stress out about it.
And I was like, yeah, okay.
And then we're like, oh I think we were gonna drop out and
then and then they're like okay but what if we rebalance
this and this and this and I felt bad because they're going
into like they're like but what if like we rebalance though
and then like because like there's more than one team that
also wants rebalancing as well so like I'm not the only one
that was like oh I don't know it feels a little off and um
and then so they're like okay we'll look into trying to
rebalance stuff and see if everybody agrees.
And I was just like, ah.
Cause we're like, this is our final decision.
And they're like, but and then they're like, okay, but what
if we do this?
And I was just like, ah.
And then my manager's like, I'm going to bed.
And...
You're like, you're like, my manager's like, I'm gonna go to
bed now.
So I don't know, I don't know if I'm in it or not.
I can't tell anymore.
I don't know.
It's so...
Ballasting is so hard.
It's so hard.
I don't blame them.
It's...
I did!
I did make the decision!
But I don't know any...
This is our final decision.
And then they're like, but what if?
And I was just like, I...
I'm so...
I thought I did make a final decision.
decision I thought I did so so yeah uh anyway I gotta make
the schedule because I still don't know if I'm part of the
tournament like I don't blame them because like um um I'm
not the only one that was like oh maybe you shouldn't look
at peak rank so now they're not going to look at peak rank
in the future if they do another another uh a third
tournament of this um yeah i know i'm trying like not make a
back and forth but then like it's like because i did make a
i was like all right because like my dad was like we have to
make a final decision on this we can't keep going back and
forth and he was like all right how about we drop up because
it does feel like there's a lot of last minute changes and
you have to post your schedule like today like you can't
keep stalling your schedule because i you know we thought it
was going to be posted like yesterday and then the day
before yesterday and the day before yes that too and that's
why the so long because i thought i kept i was like okay i
just gotta know and then i was just like i don't know what's
going on anymore like and then we're like they're like do
you want help with rebalancing and i was just like uh i have
a stream i was just like um i have a stream and also my
manager is heading to bed so so i was just like uh i can
recommend you like marvel rivals players to look through the
list and do and see if they can rebalance things so um so
basically they're working with marvel rival pros right now
to see if they can analyze the balancing situation because
they know more about the game than me so we'll see how that
goes uh mr broken body with super chat thank you thank you
yeah turkey's choice is as firm as a wet one black for chat
thank you thank you i was just like i don't know it was just
it got harder because people were like you know it's in two
days and people were like oh i think it also made it harder
just because some people were like couldn't we're like i
can't do this anymore because it's in two days and already
have other obligations to do so there was like i think like
a couple people that dropped out because of it and so so
they're like oh they had to rebalance it again like balance
it again because they're like oh shit these people drop out
we have to find uh replacements now uh for the players that
just dropped out so so now that's why it's like everything
is so complicated I don't know I do hope I did say like um I
did offer I was like uh if like um you know if I have to
drop out I did say like if they want me to stop by for an
interview or something or to commentate on the caster's desk
for a game i'll do it i just feel like uh kind of sucks that
they agree no the thing is it was an application process so
for some people that applied uh it was an application
product i was asked to because they're like oh you won last
you won uh that last tournament so um you want to come back
and i was like i'll come back if i don't have to be captain
but then like i was contacted today like i was like everyone
was contacted today whether or not they got into the
tournament, those who applied to be in it.
But, you know, you would think that, you know, they were
like, oh, I haven't been replied.
Like, I didn't receive a response.
Oh, I must not have made it in.
So then they might have, like, arranged something else after
that.
Because, you know, it's in two days, and they just got the
reply.
They just got a response today, whether or not they got
accepted to be the tournament because it was an application
process.
I was in the tournament last time, so they just directly
DMed me asking I want to be part of it.
um next thing they give a super chat thank you thank you i
think i decided whether you want to do it even though it's a
mess it's because it's definitely going to be a mess in one
way or another i think it will go okay it was just like um
just a balance there was a i just felt like the like not
just me but like me and others saw that there was seemed
like to be a balancing issue uh only to the fact that they
were using peak ranks and then some people were like um oh i
haven't peaked this months now and I were like I haven't
been playing rivals in six plus months could you please look
at me as if I was this rank instead of whatever I peaked
because whenever like they're like but then that wasn't
taking into account for so the balancing was based off of
somebody's peak rank versus what they actually are at the
moment like based off of what the game's slash skill wise is
at the moment so that was like the main issue um but like uh
but i think i think i mean last last tournament went really
well there was also like balancing issues last tournament
but they like fixed it they like redid everything only
because like they had like issues where uh people that
weren't from na uh it wasn't very clear that this was an na
only tournament so people that weren't in la na got into
tournament and had to be told to like they had to drop out
of the tournament only because they weren't na um and they
only just be like oh we thought you were na because you said
you would play in na service or some people like yeah i play
on na servers but i have but i'm from eu or i'm from asia
but i can play na servers but uh because of tax reasons uh
the like the um prize prizing and stuff it had to be na only
due to like you know when they receive uh we had do like the
tax forms and stuff and it's easier if they're all from na
versus like from different countries um so um so that's why
like that would that stuff like is that's why like
tournaments is very hard especially for like fps or shooter
games in general because there's not a lot of vtubers uh
there are v i mean there's vtubers that play shooters and
stuff but there's not but hero shooters in general it's
really hard because there's a lot of vtubers that don't play
there's all like the three roles at the elo like you can't
get find all eternity vtuber tanks you can't find all
eternity of dps uh players uh in vtuber dps players on all
teams because like there isn't it there's not enough there's
not enough uh dps there's not there's a lot of supports
though i will say as one of them there's there's a lot of
supports though uh support is a very uh uh very fun role but
not a lot of dps and tanks especially tanks wise tanks tanks
are endangered species in general uh so tanks are a
endangered species so it's very hard to balance because
there's not enough vtubers that play certain roles at a
higher elo um especially like a consistent like you know we
want all we it could be like all dps players should be like
uh let's have all the dps players be like the eternity
players or like the celestial players and then uh balance it
out like that but we don't have enough of that we don't so
or like eternity tanks i don't i think there's only one
eternity tank in this tournament like actual like an like a
not like an off-roll tank but like an actual tank player
that's uh uh that's that got into the tournament for this
tournament and like he's the only eternity slash one above
all tank like everyone else is either uh GM celestial or
like off rolling like they're like uh they're they they're a
higher rank in a different uh role like maybe support or DPS
uh like maybe they support DPS in celestial but they have to
off roll on a tank because there's just not enough tank
players so you know there's like that type of issue and
that's why like I don't like I don't blame them
um balancing because you know it's hard hero shooters are
very hard to balance especially when you're limited in your
player pool like it has to be only an na and also they have
to be vtubers and you know uh you have to look to make sure
that they're all consistent play like they're all like you
know whatever their rank is is they're not their peak rank
but their actual rank which requires you to do more research
on that too yeah so that's why it's like so that's why i
have yet to post my schedule anyway i'm gonna work on my
schedule right now because I'm just gonna put free space
I'm gonna I'm gonna put free space there I do not know
anymore I'm just gonna put free space because I don't know
if I'm in or if I'm out like and also like uh you know it's
just a lot of like uncertainty at the moment But I just know
it's gonna be announced today.
I just don't know like I just don't know if I'm in or not
Because my manager said like oh there's some people that
might drop out because they like they're like balancing is a
little bit difficult So they might think about dropping out
and I was like that means the team list is gonna change
again
I'm just like I don't know what's going on
Am I in or am I out?
Alright.
Pain.
I know.
I also want to finish Pragmata today too.
Because we've been playing that for a while.
Alright.
Let's see.
Pragmata.
Should I stay or should I go?
Took me a while too.
to be, because my manager was like, you need to make a
decision.
You can't keep flip-flopping.
He's like, okay.
And I was like, okay, but I swear to, but it's like, I do
want to play, but it's like, it's gonna, I just don't feel
like, it's just, oh my God, it just feels like, I just want
to know, like, what's going on with the teams.
And like, also, like, I also was like, also, why is this
player on the DPS role when they have zero hours on DPS?
I know, I was like, Don't complain about it.
But I was also like, it's not going to be fun for that
person, too.
I was like, I don't know if that person's going to have fun
because they clearly signed up for support.
And so suddenly they're going to be put on.
Why are they on the DPS rule?
Like, I was like, I know this person.
I know they play only support.
I was so confused.
I was like, why is this person on DPS?
And I looked up their account.
It was like, like I said, it was like less than an hour on
DPS.
on support so I was just like why wait I'm confused I'm I'm
so confused yeah so
that's why I was just like oh that's why I was just like oh
so indecisive about it but then you know when my manager was
like you we were like talking about it like on a call for
like two plus hours on whether or not I'm committing or
dropping out and then he was like you gotta make a decision
and then he was like oh he's like all right i'm gonna write
this up for you what do you think and i was just like where
he's like i'm gonna give you five seconds if you if you
don't like if you don't stop me i'm gonna send it and i was
just like okay and then he's like five four three two one
and then the sent final decision i drop out and then he was
like and then we got a reply like we can fix
And I was like, wait, wait, manager, they can fix this.
I'll turn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tomato twister.
Really, though?
Good thing to see you still going well.
Keep on going.
Don't give me a super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep, please.
Because then we found...
out like uh we weren't the only ones that were like worried
about the balancing issue so they're like well it looks like
there is a balancing issue so we're gonna try and fix this
now because we're not the only ones that mentioned it um so
they're like okay we're gonna see if we can uh we can try
and fix it so i was just like oh look see magic they're good
and he's like i'm gonna go to bed soon if you want to fix
this you're gonna have to get your your like friends who are
pros to fix this like because he was like he was like i have
to head to bed soon so we are trying to fix this Like, I'm
gonna head to bed.
You're gonna, you're on your own.
You're, you're...
Okay, so on, wait.
It's today...
Okay, finish proc today is Wednesday.
Bed drop now, and then midterm, you're gonna...
Mothra attacks you again.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Luckily, the moth is outside my room.
But yes, I changed the course of the wind while it was
flying.
So, like, while it was flying around, I was like, and then
so I forced the wind to change this course.
So it flew out the door.
And I was like, yeah, victory!
And then, you know, so it was finally out.
And then I realized I had to use the bathroom later on.
And then the moth was in the bathroom, and I was not very
happy about that.
so now and then i was like okay that's that's not great that
is absolutely not great that it's now in a smaller room and
it's harder to ignore a moth when you're peeing or pooping
so because it's harder to move your body around when you're
on the toilet when the moth gets closer so so that was not
ideal and then so i was just like all right and then Aaron
Bender Rich, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So then I was like, all right, as long as it's not in the
room.
And then I kept my door, I forgot my, to keep my door
closed, because I forgot the moth existed because I was
dealing with all the working behind the scenes stuff.
And then, um, and then so, and then the moth came back.
He found, I don't know how, I don't know why he's so
attracted to this room, but he found his way back into the
room.
I was like, why?
Because I didn't close the door.
I was like, why are you still here?
Why did you not realize that you are not welcome here.
Literally, the elements was trying to banish you from this
room, and you still made your way back.
He was, like, round two, baby.
And then so I did it again.
I opened the door.
I was like, until he flew out of that door.
And I kept my door closed.
And I started the stream.
So, um, he is currently outside.
I'm gonna, he's currently outside again.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
coughing baby versus a hydrogen bomb um but yes anyway uh
let me let me finish my schedule today is wednesday so
finish prog mod what i do i did oh yeah mouse pi for hire
that's the game i did all right let me finish my schedule
guys bump bump bump yes i do want to finish this game i feel
like playing it for a while um and we're close to the ending
i know one game that we're not close to finishing and that's
mouse pi i checked the no commentary stuff and i was like
how far off are we we're very far off it's it's surprisingly
a very very long game i was very surprised about that
all right let's see we're like not even 50 i feel like yeah
it's surprisingly very long i was not expecting that at all
i'll pay for moss membership so he can be a dragon someone
quick change your name so you get free you can get a free
members um horn thank you for the super chat thank you my
schedule guys oh i might have to order coffee as i'm getting
a little tired from from like changing the the elements to
get that moth out of here okay joki smp for tomorrow will be
joki smp uh at 12 30 and then friday will be my free space
day because i still don't know if i'm in it or not i i still
don't know
but up but up but um all right free space i don't know i
don't know what what what do we call this because i'm
worried about type free space day people will be like oh my
god what does that mean like i don't maybe i don't know i'll
be streaming streaming.
Oh, to be decided.
To be decided.
Streaming something.
Okay, I'll type that.
That's a good one.
TBD.
Streaming something.
There we go.
That's a good one.
All right.
Let's see.
And then last Saturday, we'll play Tomodachi Life, finally.
all right tomodachi life will make doki island not
affiliated with any other islands that you know of
all right what do you mean by that doki it's just doki
island tomodachi what is it fully called the new game living
the dream is that it
Tomodachi life living the dream okay yeah all right nice
okay gotta make sure it fits the
all right Tomodachi living the dream all right It's
officially on the schedule now.
All right, now I have to make the hours 26 to May 1st, May
01, which reminds me, I need to confirm about, oh, May 2nd,
that's where it ends.
26, 27.
Can't stick around waiting for lunch, but would you
recommend it?
Oh, personally, I love the beginning.
The beginning of the game is really fun.
I will say the end point leading to the end point.
Unless I think you have to get, like, I think you have to be
more so, like, you have to collect a lot of upgrades and
stuff.
But right, or do, like, the trials or whatever the fuck.
But when it gets closer to, like, the end point, of the
midpoint to the end it does feel slow it sludges a lot only
because the enemies are so tanky like i think they're like
uh to like scale it they power scale it in a way where like
to increase the difficulty of the game they just made the
enemies have more hp um but it feels like like i do barely
any damage but i think also because i just need better
upgrade i just need more yeah but I still think it like like
that was my only that was my only issue with the game it
just feels like like it takes too long to kill something yet
yeah you have to focus on building it correctly but even
then I was just like Jesus like this takes forever yeah they
basically become like bullet sponges like Like, I do enjoy
the game, but, like, it's just the end, like, as it gets
closer to the ending, it felt like they're just too, too,
like, too much HP.
Like, I feel like I'm barely doing any damage at one point.
I'm changing the time.
I hate, I hate daylight saving time.
I just found out that I was supposed to use BST instead GMT.
But it's just like, I have to change the time now, too.
don't use and like oh my god like i would i always say
everything with pst but then i got it um actually a couple
of days ago where they were like um they're like uh because
i was like oh can i have this done at 5 p.m pst and they're
like um we're actually using pdt now and it would be like if
we use pst that would be 6 p.m uh i'm sorry that would be
like uh 4 p.m.
PDT.
But like, everyone knows when I say PSC, I mean PDT.
We just don't take into account of, like, you know, we just
don't change it, but we all know.
We all know.
We all live in the same time zone.
We all...
Like, we all live in the same time zone.
PSC is PDT.
PDT is PST.
It doesn't really matter what I say.
It's still the same time zone.
It's...
Just say Pacific time.
No, don't you eat, don't.
For California.
Why is it still valid in California and Mexico?
Why?
Do I just remember?
refuse to change it change GMT to BST I'm current it's
current dokey time that's right
Mexico doesn't observe daylight savings God I wish everyone
is like Mexico right now I hate the changing of times I hate
that I gotta um actually be like you should be using PDT
right now it's like you know what I'm talking about you know
I mean whatever because we're both in the same time so you
know were both here in the same time so we're both in West
Coast we're we're both in West Coast and you know I'm seeing
the Exact time that you are in right now.
My time.
Do I use UTC?
What the fuck is UTC?
Do I just change it all?
I'll do that next week.
I'm sorry, guys.
I shall continue to use GMT.
Just assume that...
That is the GMT I'm putting it down right now is BST.
I'll fix it all next week.
I just can't be bothered to fix it now.
I...
I'm sorry.
I can't be bothered.
The passage of time annoys me.
You just gotta deal with dokey hours.
Just always assume my PST, which is actually PDT at the
moment, always the correct time and then just convert over
that even though it does say pst just assume even though we
are at beat it's it's not even though we're it is pdt right
now and i'm still using pst just assume that pst will always
be the correct time if gmt looks wrong to you uh then assume
that whatever time is pst which is actually pdt it is the
right time i know it gets a little confusing but i believe
in all of you in figuring this out with me
all right question mark question mark question mark
all right to be decided to be decided to be this oh okay
all right schedule
all right and then aside for new schedule which only has
dokey standard time on it nexi thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you we run by dokey standard time my time
baby i fucking hate daylight saving it just it fucks
everything up we had a good thing going who thought this was
a good idea why make life more complicated than it should be
it's a sham we don't need to make shit more complicated than
it should be people are too stupid for this I am people I'm
for the people right now I'm too stupid to fucking figure
this shit out properly I go where it takes me I do what time
is it I google it and then let that be the guide I mean like
What time is it now?
She has my vote.
Alright, I need to figure out a graphic for this.
I figure out what graphic to use now.
Bum-b-dum.
I hate that.
I was like, I don't care about interchanging PST and PDT.
What I use is what I use.
It's Stokey's standard time and then Pacific Doki time.
That's it.
Nothing else matters.
I'm going to use this one.
I shouldn't know.
I'm like, do I give fan service or no?
That's like always the question.
I know you guys would always be like, yes.
So then I was like, I won't give you fan.
And that helps me with my decision.
all right they like saving starting world war one and
germany's safe well then it got co-opted for farmers somehow
thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh terminator i
think it was super chat thank you thank you pdt prime dokey
time that's a good one like do i do i give fan service or Or
do I let you starve?
I need to work for it.
You got to earn the fan service, chat.
Do you think I'll give it for free?
All right, we'll new this one.
I got the perfect illustration for it now.
whoops I'm hungry well I guess you're gonna have to be
hungry for a little longer
all right wait how many months more really beginning of
April you've had so much fan service that should feed don't
make me pick that particular one don't
Don't make me pick that one drawing from Owlitt.
That's right.
I don't know if Owlitt is here, but we all know which one.
That's from April Fool's.
Don't make me bring this back.
You all wanted fan service, right?
I think it's the perfect fan service.
That's right.
Monkey paw curls.
I will do it.
Do what you want.
That would be a good time for me.
You want it to an empty thread.
Why are the tweet locked?
Because I was trying to figure out what I was trying to
figure out the graphic.
I was literally browsing through the tags right now.
Okay.
I should have just used this.
I know which one to use.
I was gonna, you know, you know what?
Guys, thanks for giving me a great, guys.
Just remember, you did this to yourself.
Because I I was actually gonna be I was actually gonna give
you guys fan service chat but look what you did look what
you did I was actually gonna use a fan service a fan surface
illustration this was what you could have had this is what
you guys could have had chat Now watch me retweet the
artwork.
That's now the artwork I'm gonna use for the schedule.
No!
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Now this is what we get.
That's right.
We were so cool.
Now we got something even better.
We got something even better.
Beach dokey.
That's right.
We're giving her more.
more our tent.
We're going to give her the spotlight she deserves.
Beach Doki.
Sexy Doki.
This woman.
You take my horse.
Spread her remains where I can see her and you won't even
give me a little bite of food.
Shake my head.
Shame on you.
And thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
It was there.
I'll even show you the... I'll even show you it it was right
there don't mind the layers just me posting pictures and
everything it's the it's a lot of layers only because
they're all the illustrations but i do delete it like i
delete it every time it gets too many i make sure to delete
the illustration layers but here i go what you could have
had is literally it was literally right there up the look at
that you can see it layer 719 layer 719 look what you guys
did it was right there
all right let me double check everything um making sure all
the times are Correct.
Was I going to do another?
I thought I was going to do another mouse PI.
Oh, yeah.
Finish.
Oh, I couldn't because there was just so many other things
going on.
Oh, oh, well.
I mean, I'm doing Tomodachi life on Saturday.
So, it should be fine.
It's just illustration layers.
It's illustration layers and text layers.
We have no power online.
You.
Thank you for the chat, Alan.
Thank you.
Alright.
Make sure everything is good to go.
If all the times are correct.
If all the times are not correct.
Look, I tried.
I really did.
Alright.
You will rule this day, bird.
You will rule it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Star, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Time to post the schedule.
Give me a sec.
I am now posting the schedule.
But, um, but, um, but um, but um, but, and not, but, um, but
um.
Uh, May 2nd.
Alright, and then...
I do need to post the references for my other outfits.
One day.
One day when I have time.
Oh, yeah, guys, by the way, thank you, everybody for we sold
out round two uh we sold out round two of the uh of the VIP
tickets for the concert thank you guys I really appreciate
it oh my god it's not expecting us to sold out so fast uh
for round two so thank you everybody for all the insane
support for the concert I was like I said I was obviously
super worried I was hoping I was worried and it was just all
I wanted was the To go well with everybody putting so much
work into it.
And everything.
So thank you again, guys.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, everybody, for all the huge support.
Like I said, I think we sold.
I think, like, I don't know.
I know, like, we sold out, like, we sold out our early
emissions.
We sold out both rounds of VIPs.
And everything.
So thank you guys so much.
I don't know if we'll have a third round.
I heard some dragoons were, like, asked.
and we can release a third round because the third round
will come from the um from the general mission so it'll be
like less general missions and more vip tickets but i could
ask for it i could ask um i could ask if we can release a
third round of vip tickets just because it's sold out so
fast so i could ask about it we didn't release like a lot of
vip tickets for the second round um i think so so we could
release a little bit more if needed but i'll ask about it
more vip's me that's true means more signatures for me to
sign that is true
let's see i think that's everything there's mistakes i did i
did the schedule live on stream so please understand I did
this schedule.
Literally live on stream.
I mean, it's literally just the next three days of streams,
but also the next one of streams is still undecided.
It's still question mark, question mark, question mark.
What's happening?
I don't even know.
I don't know what's happening.
Like I said.
Okay, let me change the waiting room for the schedule
waiting room.
We'll be next guest announced.
It's every three days, so most likely it's May 1st.
It'll be the next one.
Oh, and then let me type the community post too.
It's a best day for you, dragons.
Don't worry, I will play a game soon.
We won't finish this today.
BlackBone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for this week.
Um, sorry, it took so long to post it.
I still don't know what's going on.
what's going on for Friday.
So, I didn't want to wait any longer.
So, I let it rip.
There we go.
Other than that, we're gonna go back to the Doki SMP.
So, wait, have you guys anyone that's on the Doki SMP?
Was the parkour stuff done?
didn't mention i want to try the part i want to try like
parkour stuff on the doki smp but i don't know if anybody
built anything we're related to parkour anyone in the doki s
&p can confirm or deny it was not all right we'll figure it
out not quite has is there like um is there like uh it's in
progress all right we'll check out the parkour smp it's all
right We'll go look at construction.
We'll look at the construction.
Alright, let me see.
We're going to go...
And now we're going to visit the Doki SMP.
The Doki SMP.
Yippee.
Alright, it's just...
It's a very short...
YouTube community post.
I need to remember what I wrote for the Doki SMP.
some peace to also it's been a while for a new dragon so
mine if you remember all right here you go uh all right new
members basically mem it's basically a minecraft server for
member goons all right uh there you go post all right nice
all right
I gotta make sure we Alright now it's progamata time Finally
Alright Back at it again Back to being a tiger mom For my
child She's gonna be very successful you know She already
She's already has like after school programs She did the IB
Um She did like After school programs at Ivy League What's
your daughter done What's your kid done?
And she's only eight, guys.
Wow.
Yeah.
You know, like last summer, she did an internship at NASA.
She was literally their algorithm to help program.
What was that new ship that got sent out?
Spaceship that got sent out.
last one?
I don't even remember.
Oh my god, where was it?
Was it the Artemis?
Yeah, she was part of the Artemis 2 development.
Make sure she's not overfed on RAM.
Anyway, I heard your kid.
Just learn how to count.
How's that going for you?
Say, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She was the art of this.
It was really a flight to me.
Why do you care so little?
So I'm so sad that people don't care.
I think it's because, like, I think it's just the way media
has been, I think it's just the way media has been like
recently.
I think it was a couple of years ago because I was super
hyped when I saw, also because I was living in Asia at that
time too.
So like when I like, you know, I was watching a broadcast
when China sent their first spaceship to space and
everything was super hype.
I think like a lot of, I guess like, you know, space as well
has been like, it's been explored a lot.
Like I know not a lot, a lot, but also like I feel like a
lot of us have been very desensitized with like media stuff
that's going on right now.
And a lot of people are so terminally online at that point
that like it's harder to process new discoveries and new
like, I know I said not a lot, but you know, like, we're
always sent, it feels like we're always sending things in a
space and stuff too.
And I think a lot of media as well has been like, especially
just like processing information online has been getting
harder and harder for people.
way where there's always so much news going on in the world
that it's harder to be it's harder to process stuff in
general uh simple minded thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you guess what dokey my kid can drink water and
not short out yours cat simple they give this super chat
thank you thank you it's just that honestly um yeah there's
just so many things going on in the world now
and it's just harder to like take in newer discoveries newer
achievements in the world so i think it's also that and also
like it's also how your algorithm is like as well because
when they send out the artemis too my social media algorithm
was not pushing that much it was like i just saw like a meme
or something like a meme or two but i didn't see a lot about
Artemis 2 being pushed out so that's why I didn't like
register to me I was like oh yeah we sent out a like there
was this like we sent out a new ship right now like I'm not
on space talk yeah I'm not in the space community like I
only found out where I saw like a like a meme like after the
launch
You're like, what you see is basically the power of the
algorithm.
Because in the past, I would check out the news and stuff.
But now I get my news via Twitter.
I would actually go to Yahoo News to check out the news.
But not anymore.
You're like, who uses Yahoo News anymore?
Yahoo is so very much popular in Japan.
It still has an audience.
oh yeah that's true I thought we'd be in Mars by now I was
told in 2030 we would have cars that hover I was told that
we would have hover cars right by 2030 we are not close to
it we got you we've got got four years left what do you mean
it's 2026
we actually have self-lacing shoes though we do have
self-lacing shoes all we got was hey i slapped my daughter
being one of them you're doing great sweetie i i programmed
you to learn how to use the slide all i can do is Go to chat
GPT and help me do my homework Why did you thank Edith for
the- Bro, helicopter cars are so dangerous Have you guys
seen the vid?
It's like it's literally a drone like the car is like Uh,
you just put like several giant drones on the car and then
we're like that's a helicopter car That shit looks so
fucking dangerous
All right
for me.
Oh my god.
At Diana, please generate us holding hands.
Okay, our AI is getting better.
No problem, Diana.
Look, it's getting better.
She now can have four, it's now four fingers instead of
seven.
Yeah, of course.
Oh, look at that.
She's learning.
See, our AI art's getting better.
Stay out, Hugh.
This is my secret hideout.
Yay.
That's right.
My daughter can generate AI art.
What can your daughter do?
Yeah, we can play again.
Do I get anything from playing hide and seek with her?
It keeps glowing, so I think, feel like...
to say, I swear to God, if she hides in that spot again.
I got you.
Wow.
You're so good at this.
Aww.
I was sure you wouldn't find me there.
That's right.
I got you.
Her new outfit makes it very easy to find.
You never know when a kitty could just pop out of nowhere.
So I should carry a net.
So I can catch one next time.
You better think twice before swinging a net.
at a cat isn't a cat holographic it won't do anything anyway
cats don't take kindly to being cornered you gotta earn
their trust only then can you be their friend so just be
patient and see if they'll come around on their own okay
i'll try
also i was promised teleportation would be a thing soon what
where the fuck is my Oh, she keeps like trying to go forward
like giant ass body is blocking her way
Where am I how am I supposed to teleport one way to another?
Like where does she want to go?
She keeps where where did you want to go Diana?
She's pushing you
Okay.
I didn't want to focus more on hacking.
I didn't remember what my build was, too.
Uh...
I need more heat.
Okay, we need more money.
We could be, though.
We could have all these cool things.
What was it?
I'm trying to remember.
Decode.
Was it freeze or exposed?
What was my build?
Did I use freeze or expose, chat?
I did have a build.
I forgot.
You were using freeze?
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, do I have everything with my loadout too?
Alright, dude.
Alright, let's go.
Back to the mines, I go.
Oh, oh yeah.
We're supposed to do the trial missions.
Oh, well.
Oh, impact barrier.
Oh, yeah, no, I didn't want that.
Uh, I like the...
Oh, wait, if they are...
It's the worms, isn't it?
If they're asking me to use the...
Either the impact generator or that, it's the worm.
Forgot.
That's why I turned around.
I remember why I turned around.
Okay, no, it's a giant baby.
Oh, my God.
I hate this place.
Alright.
Well, let's just see what we can do.
There you go.
I gotta remember the controllers, but it's okay.
We have several hours.
Oh, there he is!
There's the worm!
I see you!
What's my grip gun?
Maybe he'll...
Look at that.
Nope.
Oh, oh, where are you trying to go, little kid?
Where did he go?
Oh, there's the baby.
Oh, my gosh, I don't want to...
Oh, I barely did any damage because I forgot to open the
exposed thing.
Oh, my God.
Fuck this.
I'm going this way.
Boop.
There's no way it's going to hit me from here.
That's right.
What you got to do?
That's right!
You can't do nothing about it!
Okay.
Actually...
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
John, that's where I have the high ground.
I mean, like, what the fuck am I supposed to do?
He doesn't let me shoot his face.
Okay.
Oh my god, I forgot how to swap shit.
Okay, wait.
I'm trying to figure this out.
There you go.
That should...
God damn it!
He moves when I move!
It's so inconvenient!
No, Q!
Right on!
There we go.
Oh shit!
Oh, it's my turn.
Oh,
oh yeah, that should overheat him.
Oh.
Oh, what the fuck?
He just walked away.
Be careful.
All right.
Bye, baby.
Oh, no.
No, no, please.
Give me high ground.
Okay, there we go.
Everything is fine.
I got the high ground now.
Oh, what the fuck?
How did I get here?
Okay.
How did you...
Where is the...
Is it dead?
Oh, it's dead.
Okay.
all right that's also a little a bot too uh all right
there's stuff here oh wait there's stuff over there we'll go
over there actually
okay all right it's not we gotta grab as many upgrades as we
can i'm only concerned i'm actually just only my biggest
concern is the worm not very happy about the worm right now
i'm not happy that i can't fucking kill it that's the worst
part oh that's not what i wanted to do it's all right that's
fine
it's real to hack it now right good job kenny
all right if i keep hacking
There you go.
Get
overheated.
I'm a little scared.
I'm running out of stuff.
I should overheat him, right?
Are you overheated yet?
There we go.
So take this.
Critical!
Alright.
Where are some other stuff?
There's more over here.
It's alright.
We gotta grab as many.
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
He can't get there.
He's lost!
He's so lost!
There we go.
I know he can't get here.
I'm in my little corner.
Okay, there's another upgrade right here, too.
Okay, maybe he can't make here I'm all in on the not be able
to make it part oh that's right what you gotta do now that's
fucking right all
right critical Deadly Worm does not know I exist.
Alright, another upgrade, which is good, because that's what
we need.
Then we'll hack this.
And we'll hack this.
There's no way he sees me.
I mean, I'll take those.
I mean, yay!
Let's go.
Oh, fuck.
There's no way he reaches that.
There's no way.
Nope.
We're so healthy.
I don't even know back high ground.
Just see where I can go now.
It's just, I guess I could.
Oh, we'll grab the impact generator.
I could go there just to grab for heals.
But I'm just like...
I do want to make sure that guy doesn't do anything.
I might be doing little toning damage right now, but don't
worry.
It'll all add up.
Right here.
Look at that, guys.
It all adds up.
There we go.
Oh, that's good.
That's a weapon we need, too.
Oh, we just need any weapon.
he see me we're fine there you go i know he can't make it
here
all right i know there's a john baby here but let's print
out some guns real quick homing missiles riot blaster
all right all right baby we're gonna fight the baby now
Boom!
That's right.
What you gonna do about that?
And you gotta have big ass hands.
I'm so safe.
Whoa.
don't worry I'm still safe you're going down I'm still so
safe there we go I told you critical all right doesn't look
like he's the only one left why is it so red oh that's why
Oh, let me get closer.
But where's the other guy?
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god, don't grab me.
No bad touch here.
Oh, that's awkward.
Whoa!
Dodge!
Whoa, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
He took half my HP in one swing?
That's illegal!
Oh, it's still red.
I'm actually gonna have to use a barrier.
Oh!
All right, let me use this real quick.
I'm trying here right now.
Oh god.
Okay.
Yeah, let's do this.
Oh, what?
Oh, God, to press Q.
Oh, I am moving right now.
Oh, it was because I got hit by two of them.
Oh, I didn't even know.
I didn't even notice I was getting hit by two of them.
Critical.
The fucking tag team of the century.
There we go.
Now they're all dead.
Oh, I need all of that.
I'm just gonna heal real quick too.
Okay, I have a lot of money though.
I should be able to upgrade several things now.
Oh, nice.
A little more.
There we go.
money let's go home child all right we gotta hack this oh
shit whoops I lost track of like what I'm supposed to hack
container masters yeah I'm gonna do the training mission
next because I do feel like I am under level for this area.
I might have done it too fast or something.
I don't know.
Maybe I felt like I was collecting everything I can, but I
still feel so under level.
I feel like I could have definitely leveled more in some
areas.
Can I even go through this?
I want to go through this now only because I don't have a
lot of heals for it, so I'm a a little worried.
I'm gonna go through this way.
It's just so the worm can't see.
That's right.
I do have it.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's worth it.
Because I know, like, you know, red gates are hard and
everything, so I was like, ah, man, do I take the risk?
Yeah, but he can't do shit.
shit that's
right boom easy whoa whoop it's all right i don't know cat
do anything when i'm in here
okay i needed to like get away so i can start moving oh wait
what are you doing here Yeah, what are you doing here?
It's not getting closer, is he?
I don't like when it does a little crouch thing.
It's so fucking...
All right, I need you to stop camping because I gotta push
these boulders.
Okay, I move this.
Now what?
Oh, what do I do?
Instructions a little unclear.
of this.
Okay, now what?
Alright.
Now where am I supposed to move it?
Where do I move it?
Oh, I move it all the way here.
Okay.
I can do this.
Now what?
Oh, I can move it up.
Oh!
Okay, that A John ass brain Target is up
Yeah, what's the loot here?
Oh my god, there's no way it hits me Are you Alright, that
should be legal Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay That's fucked all right you thought you can get away
with this didn't you he did he did he did get away with it
oh my god he got away with it again he actually did he's
getting away with it dokey is that really it during radio
weapon set oh my God, I wasn't even worth it.
That was not worth the struggle.
I didn't think that was worth it.
Fucking parkour shit I had to do.
It was all for a fucking mod.
Really?
It's fine.
Yeah, I don't think that was worth it.
Oh, I missed out on the box.
Oh, these boxes are...
They don't tell you in the detector That there's a box here
You can't keep getting away with it Gets away with it
Alright we open everything up I will do the red room But I
want to restock my shit If I'm doing the red room Because
right now I have nothing for it It's not worth the
commitment I'm just hoping that there might be a save file
nearby And I can just restock Yep there it is See I told you
you.
Oh, nice training data.
It is his control terminal has got to be up ahead, right?
Yeah, I hope so.
Alright, see, perfectly calculated.
I feel like we'll have to fight the worm soon, most likely.
Alright.
Wanna check if we can upgrade anything?
That's why I'm here.
That's why I'm back, Diana.
Oh, fuck, I can't even upgrade you.
We're gonna save that.
I think I can upgrade this.
I want to upgrade the heat.
Freeze.
Heat again.
And then nothing else.
Yeah, I just want to upgrade the stuff that I can do.
I can make it faster.
Alright, we're going to try and do these.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright, we're going to...
This time, guys, this time we're going to make it.
kidding.
I do not negotiate with worms.
Alright, I gotta figure out the plan here.
Double dash.
No!
Okay, we're gonna try again.
Okay.
I got the strap down, guys.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, let's stop.
All right.
We're good.
Where do I go?
I lost the way.
No!
I keep, I keep, I keep fucking messing it up.
all right
okay okay no oh my god we made it we made it nothing to
worry about nothing to worry about
yeah all right no
okay please please yes can we make it can we make it it was
one second can we make it oh we made it oh my god we
actually made it plan oh plan all right all right defeat all
the enemies oh i got hit whatever fucking cares with weapons
oh no failure condition okay There we go.
Gamer.
Why can't I hack it?
Oh my god, I'm supposed to pierce it.
I'm supposed to pierce it.
Oh, they already hacked.
I was gonna say, why can't I hack it?
Oh my god, I have to be on the low ground.
Trial and error, guy.
There you go.
Are you serious?
He actually lives.
Okay, that should kill it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
There we go.
Slow and steady, but we still made it we still made it the
horror walk i knew i had time guys i knew 100 i had time and
can't reach the target oh god not again defeat enemies in
boy no damage jesus oh my god they're all just defeat the
enemies okay reach target area
There you go.
That's right, what you gonna do.
Anyway, I'll do that next run.
I'm done with it.
It's gonna upgrade it.
I'm gonna upgrade it.
Alright.
Let's see.
I forgot you can shoot the boxes it's been so long guys i
forgot about the boxes shoot
let's see homing misses oh yeah
all right we'll do one more oh wait actually we have bingo
we knew bingo uh i feel like we got everything we wanted for
bingo i guess the triple bingo
Heal.
I don't think we need heals.
Goose suit.
Just aren't.
Yeah, it's fine.
I don't think we need it.
Oh, yes.
And we'll get another bingo here.
Bingo!
Everything?
Oh, we have one more.
Uh.
We'll get that, and then we'll have a bingo right there.
Splendid.
We look forward to seeing the new...
We hope you enjoy your purchase.
is great all right we just need triple oh then i should be
able to grab it then all right what is all right we'll try
this again
can't believe it all the cool upgrades are locked i see it
where's the box get over here
all right it's
fine we have so much time
is that it i'm
done easy okay we got another bingo all right we're gonna
get another bingo here i could do one more i could do one
more trial defeat in 45 seconds I got this I got so much
experience with it all right what are my guns okay shotgun
rocket riot blaster all right where is he boom that's right
you're going down you're going down I see you go give me
your face
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
That is a sub 20 seconds.
Wait, did I not?
Don't let enemies use antennas.
Complete within 30.
30.
You be hacked.
Okay.
All right.
I didn't.
I guess.
I guess I gotta complete it at 30.
All right, never mind.
We were close.
I have to make it so it doesn't use the antenna.
Holy fuck.
All right, we'll try that then.
I have to just keep blasting that, man.
Now it's my turn.
And then, there we go.
Well, if I knew, I wouldn't have stalled it like that.
I knew he wasn't supposed to use the antenna.
I would have definitely done it faster.
It was weapons and recycler.
That's better.
Like, I could have definitely planned it better.
We all enemies with recycler.
Whoa!
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to...
anything?
Oh, I did.
Alright, guys.
Everyone come in here.
Everyone come in here, guys.
That's right.
Oh, it's not what I wanted to do.
Wait, is that it?
Is it one time?
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize it was one try.
I didn't realize.
I thought they were all gonna let me chill.
Alright, everybody.
I need you all to get over here.
Wait, actually, is that a...
Alright, everybody get over here.
That's good.
There we go.
Alright, we got the decoy gun.
Luckily...
I was like, that has to be one gun that does all of this.
Alright, locksmith.
Reach target 23 seconds.
23 seconds?
Complete weapon.
Okay, 15 seconds.
Alright, let's try and do this in 15 seconds.
Holy shit.
What the fuck do you mean?
15 seconds.
Oh, I just got a hack.
Oh my god, I'm already fucking it up.
Oh, I already fucked it up.
I already fucked it up.
Slot.
harder than you think okay i keep like i keep smashing it
too fast
okay there we go oh i did it i like double tap it too nice
we're grabbing all the upgrades we're raining in upgrades
now okay there should be we should be good now all right oh
we should be good now target area.
I don't like the target area.
Defeat enemies with hacking nodes.
Defeat four enemies with friendly fire.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's just upgrade our stuff.
All right, bingo.
All right, we should have the gun now.
What gun is this?
This gun is apparently really good, so I don't know what it
is,
Oh!
Nose are temporary disabled.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's crazy.
That's a crazy gun.
I will just grab all of this.
Fuck, it might as well.
Oh, yes.
This is what...
Alright.
Got more bingo.
Yeah.
There's one more at the question mark.
Oh, you have quite the eye organ.
Yeah, that's good for my build.
I was thinking that, too.
I should upgrade that then.
Uh, generator, tackle unit.
I'm gonna try that out.
I'm gonna go all in.
I use all my money on that one gun.
Uh, we'll do defense.
My fucking HP is so fucked right now.
all right let's try this gun out i did multi-hack freeze and
heat oh whoops and oh wait no freeze and then riot blaster i
like the drone more uh charge piercer and this should be
That should be the photon and that should be the shotgun.
We should be good.
Alright, let's go in.
Alright, we're gonna try out.
We're gonna do the red room.
Alright.
We can grab more mats in the red room, too.
And then we'll finally progress.
Is this the right way?
I want to grab, I want to try this again.
Oh wait, I went the wrong way.
Give me a sec.
This is not the red room way.
There's new dialogue.
Take me to the red room.
Wait, where is the red?
What the fuck?
Oh, there it is.
Yes, please.
That's right, baby.
Didn't you catch me?
All right, let's try this place out.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm just gonna...
Oh!
Oh fuck!
Go in there!
Do your thing!
When can the enemy?
Oh!
Okay, that's five
All right, it's five that's
five All right, we got crit no this room is super chaotic
What do you mean bounce right off
Do they hit oh my god it does it does hit this Oh, we're so
healthy.
That's fine.
That's the last...
Well, not the last one, technically.
Woo!
These are shooting to me.
There you go.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
It closed up.
Whoa.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's it.
I'm blasting you down from downtown.
Get out of here.
Oh, there's still more.
Oh, there is still absolutely more.
But it's okay.
I have this.
Oh, what?
Okay, that's like the...
Okay, we'll get rid of him first.
Okay.
Reload!
Woo!
That's right!
What you gotta do now!
Oh, fuck!
That's what he's gonna do!
Critical!
Oh, thank God I saved all just for these red rooms.
Thank fucking God.
attacks all by themselves so we can focus on other bots all
right what did i get from that oh nice we needed that we
need pure lumen all right and we got another one of these
yeah i'm gonna keep the drone all right i do think we have
to go back and restock though
yeah no we have to restock we do not have anything anymore
we are broke whoops yeah missing I think I got everything
all right is that oh my god even check what that mod was
that I got oh no I just realized I have to go all the way
back okay I can go from here though Luckily, I could go from
here.
What mod did I pick up, guys?
I was like, I don't need to change any of my mods.
I return the shelter so I can fast travel back to the other
side.
I need to change my loadout anyway.
I need to check out that mod I got because I did not pay
attention.
Oh, enough help.
No, I know.
Maybe.
Maybe on this side.
I need an upgrade freeze.
Photon laser.
Let's grab upgrade for the photon laser.
Since we have the money anyway.
Alright.
Last shot may not break the weapon.
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh.
Okay.
So I can keep my axe.
more I don't think I need HP more ammo all right basically I
just need to kill somebody with the last shot what's this
okay we got restock photon laser I didn't worry how to use
this okay increases hacking hitting a target spawns light
blue open nodes, the deal's actually also okay.
Alright, that's gonna be fine.
And then it should be multi-hack.
And then freeze.
Oh!
Alright, back to the mines!
Always back to the mines.
Wait, why I have to go here?
Why would I be having to go to Nexus Tower?
Or Axis Point?
What am I missing here?
why is my goal here
whatever oh is that like where i last was was that basically
what that means where i was last
because i was like why is the checkpoint there i was so
confused
give me a sec i got a message here real quick
sorry i got it just works stuff boop
boop boop boop
let's see
all right let's keep going boom oh my god i'm now oh wait
this way
it is this way
yay oh yeah i forgot to type one more wait all
right Down we go!
Sorry, I had to respond to a message real quick.
Because if I don't respond to it, there'll be oopsie.
Where's the guy?
I hear him.
I hear him singing to me.
Where is he?
He's like, Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, my game eyes my fucking gamer eyes I saw that
from miles away that was crazy I did not not expect to see
that I saw my gamer eyes I knew I knew what was there my
bird eyes oh shit okay all right back I go
Broken lunaticers.
It's like a junkyard.
I'm doing my part.
Why was it there randomly?
It's not even blocking anything.
Like, what was the point?
For that to be there.
Oh, something turned on and I looked away.
Oh, there he is.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Why is he walking that way?
Hello?
Oh, okay, there he is.
I was like wondering why he was walked the other way.
Oh!
Invisible!
There we go.
You know what?
Laser!
All right, nice.
All right, we're good to go.
Nothing to...
Wait, is there any items?
No.
Nothing to worry about.
He was camping.
He was corner camping.
There is loot here.
So I know I can't go.
back up after i drop down so i gotta make sure all right
we're in the dumpster
all right nice
oh what's he doing here by himself oh i don't think i'm
gonna use my photon gun on you you do not deserve that
oh yeah yeah there's no Oh, wait, I was giving him my good
gun.
Alright.
I mean, split the hack, so that's good for me.
Actually...
Alright, that's good.
Oh, move!
Alright.
Well, I did waste one bullet.
Well, now I know there's a new mechanic.
to worry about now.
Oh, here.
I mean, what do you want me to do with it?
I can't even interact with it.
Oh, right here.
Okay, the giant glowing thing.
So this is Luna.
Luna, right?
Mm-hmm.
First time seeing it in person, though.
And I've got Luna filament inside me, too, right?
They say it can do anything.
So, sure.
Yeah, it's inside all of us.
Can I do anything too?
Maybe not anything, but...
Not yet.
Your AI is not strong enough.
We're technically, like, building a stronger body.
We can make her jack.
We just had to transfer the AI.
We had to take her to the cloud.
She's one with the moon.
Oh, we're finally out of the...
mines.
Notice for the bot maintenance team.
Since last month, we have been running lunar diggers
continuously to test automated mining operations and have
adjusted their sensor configuration accordingly.
Through our testing, we found that the emergency stop center
in the front of the machine was overly sensitive and has
therefore been disabled.
At present, only the rear sensor inside the mouth opening
remains active, temporarily retracting the armor when
triggered.
Okay.
Human detection sensor fully operation hours.
Stay clear Observe all safety procedures while the bot is in
operation.
All right.
So, wait, it's been disabled?
We just got to get inside the mouth opening.
That damn thing's getting off.
So, the mouth is its weak point.
If we could get past that armor, we could do some searing.
Hey, Megan.
Been a while.
Whoops.
I skipped his lore for this, Lord.
The story is better.
No, no, this is definitely not OSHA certified.
There's no laws in Moontown.
Dr. Higgins?
Geocracy.
Don't you just hate it?
Yeah, the moon is like international squatters, but in
space.
Oh, nice.
There's the...
You want to go back to this shelter?
do i have hmm no i don't have enough upgrades there's no
point i didn't really use much of my weapons too
all right oh that wow i wonder what's over here wow so much
open space we made it yeah Hmm, surely this is not a boss,
but...
Unregistered guests, this is your final warning.
Hmm...
Consuming presence in this area may result in physical harm
and or death.
Please withdraw immediately.
I'm calling it.
You'd make a lousy friend.
Oh, sending in the space worm.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I have to climb up this time.
I don't know to use the elevator, guys.
This time I'll know.
Yay!
Where'd you go?
Look, it's our old friend, Mr. Worm.
Running's pointless.
And just keep coming for us.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, goodbye.
I gotta figure out how to get up now.
Shit.
All right, there you go.
Oh, I would love to.
If it would open its mouth for me.
Be careful.
Go!
What the fuck I hacked it?
There you go.
Get bored.
All right.
Where's the mouth?
Oh, it's over there.
Open your mouth for me, please.
Oh my god, it's going to take fucking forever.
There you go.
Hacked again.
Please open your mouth.
Please.
Oh, shit!
I dodged it.
What the fuck?
Okay, I dodged it.
Okay, that was crazy.
I got scared there.
Okay.
I'm trying to!
Oh,
shit.
There's no way...
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, let me fucking crit it.
Alright.
One crit down.
He is not even halfway guys.
He's not even halfway
You know what fuck this?
Get rid of that goddamn armor
There you go Detachable what What do you mean?
oh oh boy we got little ones oh let me try hacking them oh
shit i did not oh never mind
oh that is not close enough that is absolutely not close
enough
oh fuck
i should use the
No!
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I hacked her up.
Get dodged!
Oh, it's a close one.
Thanks.
That's what I'm here.
Whoa!
I got him!
There you go.
Woo!
Okay.
He's still hacked?
No he's not.
God damn it.
All right, the piercer is actually very strong against this.
Oh my god, just in time.
Oh wait, I got crit.
Finally, we're halfway.
Boom!
Oh my god.
13,000.
That is big damage.
Oh, I can.
That's great news.
Oh, my God.
I'm burning.
Oh, my.
I did not expect that at all.
Honestly.
Okay.
Whoops.
all right that's not very efficient for me I'm have to use
this gun now try my best oh shit that's fine they're
slowly walking away from me all right nice oh Oh, nice.
Last crit.
Take this.
Oh, that should be the last one.
Boop.
Yeah!
The fucking tail one in the grass level had to be the
hardest boss.
The fucking tail was just too much.
This one was...
This one, the giant win, was surprisingly more easier.
More easy than the other one.
Key card at your Oh nice Level 5
Yeah this one is easier than the fucking other guy at the
fight Time to meet Edith
Alright Head towards the mainframe I'm gonna grab some stuff
just in case Okay Surprisingly no Uh no extra Uh Lord dump
here.
Ain't nothing to grab, actually.
Oh?
Alright, it's time to reboot Edis.
Ooh, there's a lot of corrupted files here.
What's with these bodies?
I think this black stuff got them.
Ooh.
Oh, no.
Now they're sludge zombies.
Hello?
Hello, Ediths?
Entrance to this area is prohibited.
He looks like Siri.
Voluntary withdrawal is recommended.
I get your withdrawal right here.
Or Alexa.
Subject has declined to evacuate.
Anti-personnel measures activated.
There's no way they put me another box, but...
I didn't fucking get the guns for it.
How is she not affected?
Is it not metal?
Oh, she's stronger.
Holy shit, she's so fucking buff.
How?
Oh, my.
I am a grown-ass man.
She's literally made of 100% metal.
She is so...
Oh my
gosh, she's hacking.
She's literally built different.
She's hacking right now.
Oh.
Oh, is that easy?
Oh, she fucking...
She DPS dipped him.
Imagine you dipped by a child.
Stop fighting!
Hello, daddy.
Hello.
Oh.
E-9900.
Administrative privileges to aid restored.
Resuming transfer of dead filament to the central port.
Thank you for your cooperation.
What is all this?
I thought we stopped it.
What?
Transfer of dead filament to the central port.
Thank you for your cooperation.
I fucking told you guys.
fucking told you.
I knew it.
I knew she was bad.
I was like, there's no way.
I called it from the very beginning.
I called it.
She was an evil child.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Her arm.
I was like, why did it lock her up?
That's weird.
You've completely ruined her.
She looks like that girl from the Sonic game.
You jerked us?
Hardly.
I truly needed your assistance.
I knew she was Eva.
I must complete my objective.
I meant across the earth.
What the fuck is dead filament?
She's hacking Nasa while cat even mod mine.
up.
Blackbones, he was super chat thank you.
Because she has white hair.
That's when you know she's evil.
I know, but like, what does it do?
What does dead filament do?
Oh, so Edis was trying to stop us from doing all of this.
I fucking knew it, guys.
I called it from the beginning.
I saw it.
I was like, that's an evil girl.
That's an evil child.
I know evil kids.
Speaking from experience.
I can see my kind.
Let's head back.
We
need to regroup.
Oh no, she's getting contaminated.
Alert.
Emergency signal.
Oh shit, I can't.
Oh, it's fine.
Don't worry, I have the heal juice here.
quick quick saver save the child only start attacking you
and i am enjoying you oh did he i see thank you the super
chat thank you thank you i thought he was attacking me no he
attacked he killed my teammates though oh wait no he didn't
experiment it was your quakes Yeah.
Sorry, it was my natural disasters killed my teammates.
The heck.
Is this tram always been here?
Here we are.
Oh my god, I can grab some stuff right now.
Okay.
Uncharged photon.
Alright.
Take me to the experimental pragmata.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
All right, wait, give me a sec.
Let me look through this message real quick.
All right.
Don't you know.
Damn it.
I like this.
Hang on, kiddo.
Model D-I-03367 confirmed.
hey Diana wait for loot oh you know they were like they were
like save her first why would she do this I'm like wait but
there's loot they just left those boxes unattended don't
worry about that
all right we're gonna 3d print you a new lay
And a new arm.
Don't worry.
Technology shall save you.
Oh, I have the power to lead stronger dead filament now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, but like, the 3D printer is right there, though.
Dispending repair.
Insufficient energy?
But the lights are still on.
It's okay, you...
Am I all better?
Yeah, yes, sweetie.
I gotta get that junk out of you and get you back on your
feet.
Wait here.
I'm coming with you.
You can't.
Not like that.
You need to rest.
I'm going.
Okay.
Let's move.
Like, what's this downside to having dead filament on her?
She seems okay.
She doesn't seem any weaker at all.
Jesus Christ, that's a big-ass 3D printer, though.
Like, she doesn't seem weaker.
She just has cool-ass battle scars now.
Now she looks even cooler.
Alright.
so i'm like tabbing in out to type stuff because i have work
never stops for some reason even when i'm streaming you're
okay without me no it's just don't overdo it all right oh
bonding with this child.
Oh.
Oh, what?
Okay, now I understand now.
Alright, we gotta get this off of you.
I thought it just looked super cool, but it's not cool
anymore.
It's no longer cool, Diana.
There is nerves to it.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to do here
all right but that's human one time where did that let you
solid thank you for this super chat thank you thank you that
is not fair take this yeah now it's a problem when it
affects me now it's a problem we'll get you fixed up soon
okay we actually have to get this off of here
It's not convenient at all.
No way around this.
We just gotta put...
Pushing interferes with Daya.
Haki will become more...
It's more purple corrupted nodes.
Alright, well I'll just stay here.
I am.
Oh no, she's lagging right now.
Oh.
Whoops, I actually did not have to go there.
You know what?
Fuck this.
There you go.
Guys, if I turn it on and off, do you think it'll help?
Someone quick, fix her ping!
Why did I get five?
She's still like this.
I hope this doesn't last for two hours.
Damn, I hope this is just a five-minute thing.
I should see if there's any extra items.
i'm missing oh oh there he is we gotta restart the round it
i gotta call tech support
hey that was you yeah that was him that was dr higgins yeah
that's right
all right oh oh that's where the objective is right more
dead fill in to give us clear actionable data to cure daisy
that is your my purpose wait what you will need to give us
clear actionable data to cure daisy oh whoops okay sorry i
have to replay that because i was like cure who that's your
purpose oh i guess we'll never know no no i missed out the
lord because i missed out the earlier Lord.
That's trying to figure out what he was saying.
I was created to help the doctor.
I told you I knew it.
I was like the doctor has a little kid.
Of course this she had something to do with it.
Oh Diana.
Daisy starts with a D.
Diana starts with a D.
It's all coming together.
All
right, there's no way you shoot.
How did you get in here?
Oh, my.
Close.
How do you keep getting in here?
Oh, my God.
He's easy.
He actually crawled through the slip.
There's no way.
He crawled.
He flew under something.
There's...
actually no way there is there's no way he must have crawled
through the underneath the door that's the only way to get
through oh my god i closed the door
he wants to know the how did he come
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is, I'm not locked in right now.
Oh, my.
Are you serious?
How you like this?
Just a little hack won't hurt nobody.
Oh my god, Mr. Broken Bot, thank you, the super chat, thank
you, thank you.
Just how did he get back in?
I literally closed the door.
That's what confuses me the most.
Okay.
I know I'm gonna do that actually.
Hope it taxed him more.
That's five.
All right.
I'm trying.
Diana!
I really am.
You're going down.
All right.
Mophus, your divine punishment for no bad service.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, open this.
Oh, okay back there.
Don't overdo it.
Okay,
okay.
All right, we don't have that.
Nope.
All right, let's just open that first.
All right, and then There we go.
I should kill him faster.
Don't worry, I'm still hacking, Diana.
Alright.
I think he's hacking.
There we go.
Get generated again!
I swear to God, if this mob is on me right now, I swear,
like, I'm moving everything.
I swear the guy and let the mob watch the ending that's I
really don't want to happen
all right holy we're almost there we're almost there Diana
we're getting them off you well all
right we're close and I have enough to do a full upgrade
too.
Like a full hack sequence for bosses that I have to.
Pretty gutsy looking bots for a pragmatic lab, don't you
think?
I think these were made to fight.
Oh no.
I don't like that.
Oh, it feels like they're going to launch them soon.
Entry is restricted for security reasons.
If you need to contact Dr. Higgins, please submit a request
at the reception desk.
For further inquiries, please reach out to the security
office.
Alright.
That sounds bad.
Oh, there's the earth.
Aww.
He didn't make it.
I'm sorry.
I can't spend it with you.
Aww.
I'm done.
No more research.
I'm coming home.
We're so close.
just hang on no so they were living apart he had to be here
on the moon for his research that's all he just wants to see
daisy again and then he couldn't she must have passed away
before he could finish his research for daisy and the
research you everything oh it's me don't say that don't say
that there's no way apparently the moth has imprinted on
this particular room I have no idea how he got in.
I literally had the door closed and everything.
I don't even know how he got back in.
My door was fully closed.
Incompatibility.
Another failure.
The results are always the same.
The pragmatist fails to adapt to the mutation.
There is no time for this.
Forget about seven.
another way.
Although lunifilament printed artificial organs remain
unsuperable for direct transplantation living humans, their
integrations into a synthetic host controlled by an AI
calibrated to a patient's physiological and psychological
profile enables remarkably faithful replication of human
biological conditions.
Consequently, mock clinical trial data sets utilized
lunifilament formulations can now be generated a level of
accuracy approaching that of a genuine human trial.
The inaugural subject pro I selected for this study will be
my daughter, Daisy.
For clarity of record, the android constructed for this
process shall henceforth be such as I designated as
Pragmata.
That's me.
Sibyan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, this is one time so I can catch you live.
I love your content.
Please keep the fantastic work.
You're a blessing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you were able to catch me live today.
All right.
was just trying to see if we could basically print out
organs
yeah so we're just trying to like print out I guess she
needed a new organ transplant or something oh the email oh
dear daddy thanks for the Christmas card I miss you but I
know you're working hard I'll keep taking my medicine oh my
god didn't realize there was a second tab how many times
were you saying yeah yeah because like Diana basically looks
like Daisy.
So her old duty was just to make sure, like, the transplant
was successful.
How many second tabs have I missed?
Compatibility.
Yeah.
I didn't do what he wanted.
Oh.
No purpose.
Oh, she was incompatible.
It wouldn't even work.
Sorry to disturb you so late.
I need to afford you that.
something urgent we receive word that your daughters can no
i mean i sort of called it though like two emails ago but i
mean that makes sense why she said she fell don't worry i'm
sure the doctor and child are fine and staff just went out
for ice cream you and diana the only ones having a hard time
mistakes they was a super chat thank you thank you all right
everyone's just on an ice cream break they're on their leave
right now they're having a retreat right
Due to capacity for degraded luna filament removal, accurate
test data could not be attained.
Initially, the use of a younger model than the target
contribute to its exclusion.
For the outpatient approximately an 8-year-old, the
malfunction observed in Dian was eliminated.
A new feature was implemented to concentrate degraded
filament.
In organisms, giving a luna filament compound a byproduct
thought to be a degraded form of luna filament appears
during metabolism.
degraded luna filament but this prevented accurate
collection of clinical trial data since such elimination is
impossible in the human body to address this failure in the
previous model diana a was instead equipped with function to
gather degraded luna filament into one place first the
priority is to refine the luna filament compound itself then
find a way to expel oh she's my younger sister then i'm
number seven and she's number eight yeah
so she's technically like a better version of me so she kept
the then fine is there fine way to expel extract the okay
okay so Diana 7 eliminated the degraded stuff but Diana 8
kept it and tried to refine it but then it like didn't do I
guess it didn't work so well like when she kept the bad
filament inside her it like made it work made her worse or
something so this is where we part ways yeah you may forget
who i am but i will always remember you eight we'll meet
again yeah yeah and then the bad filament fucked her up i
assumed i assumed the bad filament didn't do so well with
her.
Like, it did adapt very well.
Am I supposed to go?
Excuse me.
Why is there still lasers here?
Oh, it's up.
Gamers don't look up.
Who the fuck puts it above?
Diana represents the first Pragmata prototype equipped with
an effective AI architecture capable of producing facial
expressions closely allowed with those of Daisy at
approximately six years of age.
While insinible for the objectives and attended experiments,
we could not quite bring ourselves to scrap it outright.
The data gathered so far is bound to prove useful in some
form.
Has been placed in indefinite storage, awaiting a research
application suited for its capabilities.
Furthermore, to limit the possibility of residual test
records producing confining outcomes in future they wiped my
memory.
That makes sense.
That's why I couldn't remember anything.
It's coming to my attention that Diana and Diana ate college
years 7 and 8.
Presumably they're using the last digits of their ID numbers
as nicknames.
They were already a Daisy when she was even younger.
She was always good at giving her stuffed animals and little
pets unique names.
Although we based their biometric data on Daisy, I didn't
expect them all, like, they gain, what's the call it?
Um, not fruit.
Sentience.
They gain sentience.
Could this rally really be a coincidence?
No, it's best not to overthink it.
In the end, their prosthetic bodies built for Daisy's
treatment.
Nothing more.
That's fucked.
He was just like, I don't care.
Daisy is priority number one.
Science.
Forever.
Here we go.
A reactor.
He didn't care.
All he cared about was...
All he cared about was Daisy.
It didn't matter to him that the robots gained sentience,
even though that is an insane scientific achievement.
Paying more power.
Damn it.
Yeah, but they could be daughter two and daughter three.
Yeah.
How you like this?
Oh, shit.
All right.
There's so many things in front of me right now.
All right, let's do this.
Just because I can...
have to worry about anything our
last one oh yeah they could be like well use your sisters oh
no oh she used the ball she's at one percent battery guys we
got five to charge your stat
hold on we're gonna get you better don't worry we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna do an
Come on.
Stay with me.
We're gonna find an antivirus.
It'll clean you up.
We're gonna wipe all the viruses.
Does anyone carry a battery bank?
Anyone?
It's funny, but a positive result.
This could be the key to saving Daisy.
All thanks to you, Eight.
We must proceed carefully, but...
With your help, we'll get there.
I guess I will have to pull the plug on seven.
Oh, why?
But it's served its purpose.
Well, maybe she didn't like that they were going to destroy
seven.
So she, like, she, like, rebelled against everybody.
Oh, I'm useless.
No, you're not useless.
We can use you to find you.
Crypto.
Hi, Toki.
Every GPU CPU has its purpose.
Wait.
Hi, Toki, please.
All right, we got a bad...
We got a new battery.
Oh, come on.
You're not useless, Diana.
Okay.
What's all our memories of me?
Of everything.
It's all our memory.
That's me.
Are these your memories?
It's your eyedrive.
You're not useless.
Stop saying that.
Don't think like that.
You'll have an 80-90.
Think about what you want.
Someone will always It was one in 80-90.
With you.
Oh.
We backed up her memory.
So, like, if anything happens, at least we still have it.
Why are we deleting?
Deleting a bad filament right now?
Yeah, that's good.
Real good.
Just hang in there.
And we'll go anywhere you want.
I want to take a vacation, Lan.
Oh, that looks like, that looks very evil.
You think he's friendly sheep?
Wait, who's gonna hack?
Wait a minute!
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh no, I think it's just, it's just a dodging game right
now.
Yeah, I was going to say.
We don't have a hacker.
Oh, damn.
I can't take this thing all alone.
But hell, if I'm going to leave her here.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Wait.
All right.
Don't worry.
I could sunlock this guy for...
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Oh.
I don't know how I sunlocked him for so long.
I hit every 50-50 roll.
Something's changed.
Oh my god.
They installed.
She got installed a new update.
There was a new firmware update.
Oh my god.
She's going super soon.
she has she destroyed the malware yet the graphics driver
update
good job Diana I thought I lost you nice fight get up she
has admin powers good job I'm so proud of you you're
definitely going to Harvard now oh my god I'm not sure if
fix or an upgrade yeah did i do good you did great sweetie
you did great hey hugh when that black stuff got on me i
just felt so sad and empty sad huh like you picked up on her
feelings or something through all that gunk
time but what she's doing that's wrong yeah i think so too
yeah she's a bad person
all right come on get on my back we're gonna kill an evil
child now but that's okay she's evil what what's going on
what happened oh Wait, I got dead filament on me.
Wait, how do you get on me?
We're out of here.
This overdrive has been upgraded when Activate opens nearby
enemies.
Temporary disables auto movement and deals heavy.
Oh.
Okay, so that's my ult now.
Oh, shit.
I don't remember when I got stabbed.
I thought it just got better.
It's this way.
Yeah, I don't remember that.
I thought I just got better, you know?
He,
he, he, he, okay.
Boom.
Does I make a clean cleanse that?
Oh, I can cleanse that too.
All right, we gotta get the money.
All right.
Boom!
Give me that money!
There's more block in the tram too.
I'll handle it.
Alright, we got it.
We have enough to upgrade too.
Fixed up Diana.
A new destination has been added to the tram line.
The central port is now accessible.
all right oh last area area six we're almost there let's
head to the central port we've got to stop eight and get
back to her yeah new upgrade i bet you i won't die that is
just gonna kill me she's gonna fix me with shiny new stuff i
believe i think eight she can fix me i wonder what is Okay,
nice.
I can upgrade Diana even more later.
There's no way.
She can fix me, guys.
I believe.
Okay, we gotta get the mod slot.
And then I want to save up for more thrusters, for another
thruster.
And then maybe...
Actually, I should get the deletion protocol.
Honestly.
You know, I should do i'll update expanded our stamp for oh
more stamps if you're interested stamp i'll grab a gate card
oh yes this is one of our more popular items thank you for
your patronage
there's what a balloon
they'll just deflate the balloons all okay yep they're all
there look at you go i was always popping or losing every
balloon i saw um what's wrong well the truth is how that's
all part of why did she lose it we're all we've all you
haven't brought a balloon to the mission where did it go hey
diana Have you ever been swimming?
Nope.
I don't think we can put her in water.
Yeah, I was going to say, can we upgrade her to make her
waterproof?
iPhones are not waterproof.
I see.
Well, don't worry.
Stay close to the shore first.
There's no way.
If iPhones can be waterproof, so can she.
We must have unlocked the technology.
I believe.
We'll just spray those, like, you know those sprays.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, she lost two.
She lost three.
Oh, did she not look up?
I'm trying to think if I should...
I'll do, like, some more challenge.
I'll do, like, two to three more.
Grab some upgrades.
Destroy all storage boxes complete without taking damage.
That should be fine.
All right.
What the fuck am I looking at?
All right, let's retry that.
I already fucked it up.
I dashed through my gun.
Wait, how do I get across?
Excuse me?
Like, how?
How am I?
Is there, like, something I'm missing?
Oh, that!
Okay, I get it now.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
it it's the platform all right i get it now okay the
platform moves so slowly that it doesn't register to me that
is moving you know like look how slow this moves
i'm not patient enough for this i will say i think i just
might not be patient enough
i think that's my issue
enough for this fight trial.
I just want to move.
I don't want to wait.
Waiting for losers.
Ah!
Let's find another one.
I can't stand still enough for this.
I can't stand still.
Patience is a virtue and I don't think I'm very virtuous
right now.
Unfortunately.
Uh,
unlucky.
let's get this real quick and then grab that and then get
that real quick
there we go you should start killing each other now
all right you should kill each area we're just gotta wait
come on just one more hit just one more hit come on Oh, no.
Nice.
Got it.
Got him.
Good job, Kenny.
Oh my god, it's 14 seconds.
Come on.
Nine.
Yeah, we made it.
See, okay, see, that one was easy.
That one was fine.
I was able to get that one out of the way.
It's just the standing still part.
Alright, so I'll storage bosses with weapons in 90 seconds
to complete.
Here's try.
Alright.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Guess that's that.
Something's aiming at us.
Alright.
Oh, is this just trash?
Tracking?
Alright.
Grab this first.
Where's the last one though?
Five, six, seven.
Where's the last box?
Do you guys see it?
Where is it?
Eight.
Where's the fuck is the last box?
box
oh my god couldn't find the last box we that got it I got it
I didn't I didn't even see it I didn't see I saw like four
out of five no my yet it's fine I knew this again it's me
trying to figure out where the fuck the last fifth box was.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't even see I didn't get him.
Okay, where was it, guys?
Okay, where?
It's fine.
That doesn't matter.
Very tall.
I see it.
Alright.
It's just tracking.
There we go.
Easy.
Alright.
Nice.
We figured it out.
I'll do like one more for upgrades.
Uh, reach target area and dies.
Defeat enemies with weapons.
Yeah, I'm just gonna do the defeat enemies part.
That one is much simpler than...
Uh...
Than reaching an area.
For some reason, my brain does not want to reach anywhere.
okay all right we can do this again
all right
there you go
yeah all
right that should kill it
all right what
the fuck all
right that should should kill it.
Oh my, there's more.
That's just unlucky for me.
Whatever.
I do not care anymore.
Fuck this.
Oh, fuck, I pressed the wrong button.
Whatever.
That was a little oopsie on my end.
That really was.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
That should kill it.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Get out of here!
all right that should kill it soon okay it's over there
all right that should almost kill it there we go we did it
we fucking did it oh oh these upgrades all right summit
destroy all I think we got enough upgrades.
That should be enough.
We can have another Diana.
And then...
I want to grab the hacking one.
The delete protocol.
Oh, I was just getting the...
I forgot.
I wanted the thrust.
It's fine.
Whatever.
And a bingo.
And I want to grab another red card.
more bingos we are honored please enjoy your purchase
alright I think we're ready alright Diane we're ready okay I
thought I saw the I saw it in my peripheral vision I I saw
it I was like what was that what was that my coordinate what
was that
yeah he don't know he and then i don't do i oh i do attack
no drop rate grab the heels
huh i will grab that
all right yeah it's the mind games you ready to do this I'm
ready.
Yes, I am.
I will stop her.
But, I can't believe she's acting this way.
We're both Pragmata.
So, there's gotta be a way to get along.
Together.
Pragmata or not, doesn't mean she'll listen to what you've
done today.
Pragmata's strong together.
We just don't want to hurt her.
Oh, that's sweet.
We're gonna kill your little girl.
Let's see what we can do.
it's all right sometimes lying is okay
sometimes it's okay to lie to a little kid she's got she's
gotta learn
oh what the oh new mechanic i guess
all right this is where all the dead filament's going huh we
gotta stop her damn ray Do anything here?
Any enemies hit with a cleanse would take damage, charging
the attack for longer.
Oh!
Wait.
Whoops!
Whoops, that's awkward!
I thought the range, to be fair, I thought the range would
be a little bit further.
I really did.
I didn't think the range would be that short.
Boop.
I don't want to use my nodes right here.
We gotta save it up.
Oopsie.
Yeah, I thought it would be like further.
Like, further.
The way she was charging it up.
Made it look like she was gonna Fucking Kamehamehameha.
Okay, why the fuck did that not go through?
Yeah, I was gonna say, why did that not go through, though?
Alright, it's elevator time.
I'm about to use the drone here.
I know, I know I saw the targeting cone, but then I was
like, surely it's not that short.
Oh, there's things here.
are going to show up.
Oh.
My game crashed.
That's awkward.
Uh.
Report data is being generated.
The data can help resolve issues and improve our services.
You may be asked to provide this data.
All right.
We're sorry for inconvenience.
We're Sending the data off the Capcom right now.
Capcom's like, what the fuck?
Alright, data's being sent over.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Oh, just waiting.
How am I...
Yeah, I was gonna say, why did it crash?
What the fuck?
We gotta wait.
I'm just waiting.
Oh my god.
Alright, that's it.
I'm canceling the data report.
You're not getting this data.
You're not getting it anymore.
Fuck this.
You took too long.
Oh my god.
Now I have to load.
Now it's loading.
Oh my god.
all right we gotta wait it's that's it i'm i'm forced
canceling everything the is my task manager that's not my
task manager where's my okay uh pragmata all right we delete
the crash report you're not getting this data and delete
that and then we're gonna reboot Oh, surely it's not too far
away.
Right?
Well, let's see it.
Let's hope it's not corrupted.
Also, I just found out my schedule.
I fucked up my schedule because I fucked up the next day
for, obviously, as always, I messed up GMT times for the
schedule.
I forgot to change the little thing.
You know how?
Oh, my God.
Why is it still running?
Stop.
Unsafe data may be lost.
Oh, no.
It's generating right now.
Oh, I gotta wait.
I gotta wait, guys.
It's waiting time.
That's it.
I'm pressing stop.
If there's unsaved data, then I end.
If there's unsaved data and it doesn't even get me If I lost
everything from this playthrough?
You know what?
The stream stops.
The stream shall stop.
Don't do this to me.
Surely that won't happen.
Guys, surely not.
Surely we keep our data, right?
Don't worry, I believe I believe in keeping the data I truly
believe Alright The moment of truth Everybody I'm a little
worried Alright everyone The moment of truth Here we go any
any minute now
um all right where am I this I swear to God I don't even
know I don't know guys did everything anything save I can't
tell okay I got the lead okay wait I don't remember okay the
only way to remember is if the training module
Okay, yes, we got...
Okay, everything seems fine.
We're good, we're good.
We're good.
Oh my god, work message as well.
I was going through all of this.
Hmm.
Uh, why are they?
I don't
know.
All right, I have everything quibbed.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, it's saved when I was there.
Transport somewhere in here, right?
All right, we're back here.
God damn it!
Oh, these messages!
All right, here we go.
Back at it again.
Boom.
All right, I grabbed the...
is so this is where all the dead filaments go all right if
we crash again then i don't even know damn ray let's move
all right now that we know i'm charging we just got okay
that's all right all right
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna...
Oh shit!
There's a lot of hacks going on.
I didn't even notice that!
Take this!
Alright, last one.
Done.
Alright, see, that's a lot faster.
But I wanna walk on the goop though.
There's money on the goop.
Alright.
Let's try again.
If we crash again, then I just don't think it's salvage.
If we crash again, guys, I think we might be soft locked if
we crashed again, chat.
I wonder why eight wants to take that second time's the
charm.
Doesn't matter.
If it gets loose.
Okay.
Hello, I'm alive.
hello everybody okay so we have an issue right now which is
figuring out okay i'm gonna go repair pragmata and see if
that works i'm gonna repair the game right now guys um
that's awkward i repair again browse local files what the
fuck how to repair at desktop browse hides this game of game
files properties up where the fuck is the repair view
integrity all right we're repairing we're repairing the game
oh that's awkward
oh i just want to i just want to finish the game how close
am i
everything went downhill all because of the trap
all right just give me a sec i'm just i'm repairing right
now it's all i could do it's all i could do um yeah the moth
laid eggs there's no way the eggs would have been burnt up
guys you know it there's no way the This is almost like the
Delta Run Street.
Think of the Super Chat Broken Pod.
Thank you.
All right.
It has been repaired.
Let's see how this goes.
I think it's the tram.
I think it's the...
I don't know.
Whatever it is, is overloading everything.
And then everything just crashes.
Whatever it is, it just crashes everything.
Mothra.
super chat they could thank you i'm sorry i got too freaky
lower all your i'll do that i'll try that she hacked it too
much she doesn't want me to stop it she hacked it to my pc
to make sure
i know i was like what did they how many polygons are on
that trap honestly no it literally broke my encoder settings
it was like Encoder error.
Your child got corrupted.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whatever is at that tram has like 800 terabytes or some
shit.
Which is crazy to think about.
Yeah, ever since my child got that upgrade, it's all been
downhill.
Alright, let's go.
Display.
graphics um where the fuck do i do the settings for this
yeah it's not even processing that much quality yeah we'll
do 50 here um what makes it shadow cash what else can we do
uh All right, just remember all of this.
It was on lowest.
Okay, remember all the stuff I did, guys, because I'm not
going to.
Just help me remember everything.
It's going to look very ugly soon.
No, I don't think it needs...
It doesn't matter.
All right, remember everything for me.
Holy fuck.
Guys, we gotta get through this.
We gotta get through.
Don't worry.
This will be over soon, guys.
I'm toky.
I'm not strong.
Guys, make sure to remember everything I turned off.
This is all very important.
Because I don't remember what I clicked, guys.
Guys, I need you all to remember this.
I need to deal with this.
Stop the functions.
Thank you, Super Chat.
I'm going to see you.
Thank you.
Let's move.
Oh, shit.
She's all right.
Why am I lagging?
Wait.
What?
Okay, we might have to...
I don't understand.
How am I lagging with that?
guys what did i we're gonna go back we're gonna does anyone
remember what i clicked because i don't all right shadow um
bloom was on um what else that's all i'm going to this game
is cursed
what else what else was on okay how does this stop the lag
That doesn't make sense!
That works on bots too.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I can't be bothered.
I don't know how I stopped the lag.
When I raised everything up.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go again.
Alright.
Alright, what are we doing?
60 FPS.
50% quality.
Um.
What else do we do?
I already forgot.
Shadow cache, content, chat.
No, it's fine.
We don't need to do that.
Uh...
Do we do anything with this?
Oh, 30?
We're going to go with 30.
Just bear with me right now.
Alright, bloom.
Alright.
Alright, we're in.
Oh my god.
Just bear with me.
We gotta make it back.
the trap we got it we got to make it past the trap this is
it hold if I look at the ground maybe if I don't gender if I
don't look up oh god this is so disgusting it doesn't matter
it's so beautiful playing on my no
Guys, I think we'll, there might be a chance We will never
finish Pragmata.
Oh my god, it killed My streaming stuff too.
Alright.
The stream Didn't die.
Yes, but V Bridger Died.
Maybe you need to send a report, Toki.
I don't know what to do.
Are you even prepared?
It's okay.
All right.
What if I have an idea?
Yeah, okay, wait.
How far?
How far left of the game?
Time to wait for it.
Wait, I have an idea, guys.
I have an idea.
I don't know what to do.
All right.
We're gonna fix this.
I even, I don't think like I did.
I check file integrity and everything.
I have an idea, guys.
All right.
This might be a little scuffed.
But if it'll work, it'll work.
All right.
There's two hours left.
I was actually going to pull it up on YouTube and pretend to
play the game just so we can at least get the end.
All right.
This is my idea.
This should take, there should be less, less, like, you know
what I mean?
Should be, it should be like less processing power.
So surely now that I'm also a child.
Surely there'd be less processing power for Pragmata now.
Yeah, less resources.
It's just that tram.
It's hilarious.
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
All right.
Okay, we're gonna turn it all off.
We're gonna turn it all off.
I'm gonna be a little guy.
Give me a sec.
All right.
We just got...
get through the tram that's all we need to get through it we
just gotta get through the fucking tram system that's it
like the moment we pass that everything will be fine all
right let me find a screenshot to use there we go
here we go tweak just we just gotta get through this We just
need to bypass the trap.
That's it.
Oh my god.
It's so ugly right now.
Alright.
This one area.
I'm so close to finishing this game.
But this one area.
It's one fucking area.
It's actually like the bane of my existence.
Like, I don't understand how much they're offloading right
now.
It's so crunchy.
Transport somewhere in here.
It has...
This game has been so...
What's the word?
Like, stable?
Throughout it?
It's just this area.
What's that word?
It's, it's, like, not stable.
There's a specific word for it.
So this is where all the dead filaments going, huh?
When like we had no frame drops, we didn't have any issues
whatsoever.
Optimize, yeah.
Everything was so optimized before.
I don't understand.
Like it was all so optimized.
Alright.
Yeah.
Alright, I didn't update my NVIDIA driver in a while, too.
Maybe that's what I need to do.
Maybe.
I remember, I think I updated, like, five to six months ago.
That was the last time I updated it.
So we might have to update the driver.
But then if I update the drivers, I'll have to restart my
PC.
I wonder why 8 wants to take that stuff to the earth.
there's no way wait hold hold oh my god we made it that oh
my god we made it past the trap oh my god wait we did it all
right time to set this all back guys all right does anyone
remember what this looked like before because i do not i i
need it guys all right cat it was shadow cash i remember
that there was bloom i remember that and then i don't
remember anything else did i turn anything on and off chat
the final boss no Is there anything else?
The tram isn't over.
Volumetric on.
Is this?
Oh yeah, it was this.
Whoa.
Grab that on high real quick.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
We stopped.
oh my god we're here we're here all right we're gonna kill
all these we're gonna try and get off the tram first
actually i think it'd be better if i got off the tram
honestly
all right all right i'm gonna be like i'll kill you
oculation is also on high all right
whoops that's fine he's dead now i gotta get off this tram
first before i do anything
all right okay the tram is starting again our ambient
oculation was also on the fuck was that all right now
everything looks beautiful hey diana don't count on eight
hearing you out anymore yeah yeah
whatever happens don't hold back got it alright we made it
guys we got through the the final bus the goddamn tram we
made it I see the tram I can't do this to me.
I see the trap.
Oh.
Alright.
Whoops.
I'm gonna kill this first, actually.
Boom!
Oops.
This guy don't need a jump.
Alright.
Nice.
Let's get to the orbital elevator.
That's it.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
We did it, guys.
First boss down.
We're off the tram.
Wait, we gotta make sure we get to a checkpoint, too.
Oh my god, please tell me there's a checkpoint nearby.
Oh, thank god.
Out of the tram.
Out of...
Thank fucking god.
Alright, let me go grab this real quick now.
It's all it took.
It's all it fucking took.
Alright, out of the danger zone.
We have the checkpoint.
We're just gonna...
I'm just gonna keep it at the baby.
We're gonna end it with the baby.
Fuck it.
all right we're ending it with the baby
that's the best we can do baby put baby all right little
baby mode cargo bound for earth must undergo inspection be
delivered to the designated warehouse with the proper permit
Additionally, anyone returning to Earth must receive a vital
signs check at the central port.
Alright, that's fine.
He's reasonable to ask.
I'm going to send dead filament to Earth as shuttle cargo.
She's trying to use the transport?
Yeah.
And if she succeeds, we're out of a ride.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him above me.
Yeah.
I don't see him, though.
He's like right above me somewhere.
Oh, goodbye.
It's nice knowing me.
It's like somewhere here.
Like I hear him.
Oh?
Oh, he got upgraded.
Wait, can I cleanse it though?
Can I?
Okay, cleanse my power.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say I have to just cleanse it.
Get over here.
Boop!
There you are.
That's right.
You're not special anymore.
There we go.
Easy.
Oh!
Charging.
Boop!
That's right.
No longer Special!
Where?
Oh, there he is.
Boop!
That's five.
Alright, easy.
Alright.
Easy.
Baby Doki did it.
Oh my, there's so much loot, too.
I can't be bothered.
I'd lost so much time.
trying to get through the trap
oh whoops oh my god it was from here oh my god all right
whoops whoops we'll get it eventually
okay that might be the yep that's where the loot is never
mind we actually did get the loot oh it's the
No.
Oh, that still hits me?
Oh, I thought I would get that first.
I got a little too cocky.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Oh, never mind.
He does not care.
Oh.
All right.
All
right.
All right.
Okay.
Boop!
Alright, that's fine.
Critical time!
Yay!
Money!
Yippee, money!
I figured out where to go.
I guess up here?
Oh, here.
Alright, parkour.
Never mind.
Now I parkour.
Alright, grab that.
Confuse.
Any items?
Okay, upgrade.
Lore.
Oh.
Oh wait, not printing.
Okay, we need a second gun here.
Oh, it's fighting time.
It's battle royale time.
We need to cleanse them.
Cleanse.
Alright, it's fine.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
That's like fight each other.
I'm gonna heal.
You two fight each other.
I'll do this that's right fight fight fight there you go
he's so confused it's like why am I fighting my family okay
you don't fuck this here I really can't be bothers.
Too many.
There's no way there's going to be another one, right?
That'll be pretty awkward.
Oh, my God.
What?
What's on top of its head?
Oh, I'm trying to shoot it.
All right.
One core down.
There we go.
all right there you go that's a lot of missiles too i'm
standing out out over hate
oh my god it has to be the last one right wait he's still
alive whoops
that's my bad i didn't realize he was still alive i was
ready to clock it i was like go time to leave
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna grab that.
I still don't know where the...
That?
No.
I don't see it.
I don't see the little...
Mom!
The mom!
Fine.
Holy shit.
Dead filament.
This won't be nearly enough.
But we are to cause a global chain reaction.
We need all the dead filament we can get.
What does he want to do?
What is her master plan?
I peeked at Jacob's terminal the other day.
It looks like the higher ups are worried about some kind of
black substance.
I couldn't make out all the details.
But I did catch fragments.
Apparently, the Zalas are creating mad...
What?
has been found that Dr. Ken even handles bad enough to melt
the entire U.S.
Oh my god, even the world.
Her plan is to destroy...
If we destroy the world, then she'll never have to cure
anybody.
And that means her objective is complete if you think about
it.
If there's no one alive, then her objective is complete.
She's using dead filament to destroy the Earth.
It's like all my sci-fi shit if no one is alive then she
doesn't need to complete any objective she's so smart she
figured it out I swear to God this is another tram guys this
is oh no guys it's another tram
That's dead filament.
Yeah.
Oh my god, we fucked up.
We 3D printed too much, guys.
I mean, that's all we have to save the world.
Oh my god, the slowest fucking elevator in my life.
Every elevator.
every trap I'm gonna be like sweat but it's not a straight
shot to the orbital elevator is it looks like we'll have to
go through that building okay we'll head to the orbital
elevator we can never be safe training sims did we get that
should give us access to a red zone oh the sector managed
priority projects associated the proposal submitted to earth
hq through the census natures these projects it all acts all
access is continuously like all right scan run you upgrade
anything with that oh yeah i can upgrade stuff the trap ptsd
it only took us one stream crash three game crashes uh power
porn emulator to figure it out.
Yeah, we're at the beach.
Yeah, it's to hide free from the sun.
Aww, look at her.
She's role-playing.
She's getting immersed.
Yeah, and a shark, too.
A parasol is basically a roof.
But underneath, it feels like my own little space.
I know what you mean.
It's like a cozy home with no walls.
Yeah, it helps you protect you from cancer.
From the UV lights.
Thanks.
I'll bring a cooler back with some drinks when I do.
Oh?
What's that?
I see.
Oh, it's a flat...
Oh!
I hope my flower is still okay.
There's a flower headband.
Probably all be wilted by now.
The Luna filament plants that grow on their own, yeah?
They're way too delicate.
Wouldn't stand a chance growing in the shelter.
Turns out REM flowers suit you just right.
I think so too.
Oh, she's happy with that.
I don't know, do I have enough for an upgrade?
I do it for a gun.
I'm gonna do gun.
and then we'll work on uh hacking upgraded up next all right
i did want to get thrusters and then another protocol and
then we'll work on oh there's new hacking stuff i think the
heat one is honestly the best one
whichever offense or which one was the combust mode all
right we're gonna do uh we're gonna for your guns after all
right give me my bingo bingo yeah bingo all
right we got chain that emily processes channeling and
hacking adds bonus damage based on consecutive node uses Is
this a good one?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck.
Wait, this looks like a good one, actually.
I'm gonna try that out.
I'm surprised I don't have more, like, hacking nodes.
Yeah, it's complete.
Alright, let's see.
Let's fix our loadout again.
Photon laser.
Go to a code generator?
Let's grab heat.
Okay, I want to try that.
That, and then this can be heat.
And then...
Multi-hack.
I'll try that.
I'm ready.
I guess something's going to do.
Unlock the final boss.
Wait, I like that.
That sounds good to me.
Ahur's sunlock.
I'm ready to party.
Oh.
This does not look very linear.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
Oh shit, that's a...
That's a gun.
Yeah, I'm not wasting shit on you.
Is that it?
Alright.
Ah!
I ran out of stamina.
I just wanted to grab the upgrades.
Oh, wait.
There's a box here.
Upgrade, upgrade.
Okay, yeah, I had a feeling it was a fucking bingo.
That's all it.
That's all there is in those boxes.
It's just bingo cards.
Oh, that looks like a boss fight.
I see a printer there.
Let me grab my charger.
Let me actually, let's grab my drone real quick.
Move, Q.
Get in close.
We need to plunder his core.
There we go.
Try it.
We got your core now.
Oh, shit.
I did not see that, Walker.
Oh, she has to reach.
All right, that's not great for me.
Boom!
Yep.
All right, you go do your thing, drones!
I'll kill this guy first!
There you go.
Whoa!
That's fine.
Oh, that's no longer fine.
I owe you one.
Yes, it's my turn.
Boop!
There you go.
Gotta shoot the thing, I'm behind him.
That's right, right behind you.
Oh shit.
I exposed the core.
Bye baby.
Bye bye.
E- oh wait, there's more?
What do you mean no idea?
Oh, God, I think it's all organic.
I'll take care of it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God, that's just pure organic matter.
What?
Okay.
Diana, you okay?
All right, there we go.
All right, that's fine.
boom all right we got the core off are you kidding me oh god
okay all right we got we got back oh okay these guys are a
lot tougher i'm already used up like four heels for that
foot that was holy he did so much damage too i was not
expecting all that damage we can't go this way can you get
rid of this stuff maybe if we can get it at the source all
right go to cleanse the filament i need a i need a reset my
hp I don't need to buy anything, but my HP is not looking so
good.
No, it's like, it has organic matter.
It's like, like the dead filament.
The dead filament has got sentience or some shit.
Upgrade the chain.
And then...
I can't upgrade anything else.
Like any of my stuff that I actually use.
That's bad.
I guess I have to upgrade heals now, for real.
Yeah, now I have my stuff now.
Alright, I can recharge my guns, too.
I need it.
Freeze.
Right?
Was it freeze?
Yeah.
Oh!
Like, I was tough, because I needed to...
uh do the blaster thing i needed to like use the e or some
shit which where's the goal okay that's the goal that means
this is extra this project began with early lunar
development to transfer process lunar filament other
essential materials by sliding designated containers through
a network of pipes spanning the cradle.
We established a low-cost, rapid transport system.
Transport penal insight is strictly prohibited due to
concerns.
So that's how it's moving everything around so fast.
We don't have much time.
Yeah, we don't.
Okay.
All right.
Let's keep things up.
Whoa!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I need to charge up a little faster, though.
There we go.
Alright.
That was real close.
Oh my god, I'm fucking threading the needle right now for
you, Diana.
Yeah, we got through that.
Oh, nice.
all right we got the extra loot bingo tab bingo tell me you
got something anything else here wait how do i get this then
oh looking of course every time every time always gotta look
up
okay wait that should be good that's the eminence The heat
gauge thing.
God damn.
Why was I born such a good gamer?
I just...
God.
I just never look up because of it.
Just too good.
You know those moments?
You're too much of a gamer.
Oh shit, that's me.
You know, when you're just too good of a gamer, guys, don't
you just hate it?
God, it's so hard to be me.
What a good gamer.
I just hate it.
Alright, here we go.
What?
Alright.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
I was not expecting that.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Oh my god again.
It like fucked with me so hard.
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
Fuck that.
Oh, that is not a lot.
Okay.
It's like right here, too.
Oh god.
Oh, fuck, I didn't see that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, my god.
Okay, I'm all over the place with that one.
Oh, fuck.
All right, that area was fucking hard.
Let's take a break.
Oh, please tell me I still have my upgrade thing.
All right.
Don't.
I don't even get to keep it.
Okay, we gotta... I don't know.
I feel like I gotta keep that heat, obviously.
Freeze, maybe?
And then...
Pierce.
For sure.
Pierce, and...
Yeah.
We need that, actually.
I'm gonna...
I'll get rid of that and get the heat.
The only issue is we don't have to have now oh is it impact
barrier oh I should get the in oh it's too late I'm already
committed yeah the impact barrier would have been nice too I
should have went with the impact barrier I don't even I
don't have any hacks now for him yeah tough to get in close
wait I have to do this wait do I have to do this again over
on the other side or did it already got it yeah I already
got it yeah I should have just used the dome get the ride
blaster out oh my god tripped oh my god I tripped again all
right let's try this again
Oh, that area is rough though.
Oh, wait.
All right.
We got that out of the way.
I owe you.
Wait, what?
That should have... Oh, wait.
There you go.
Whoops.
Take this.
That's fine.
Nice.
Yeah,
let's do this.
Oh.
Fuck!
Alright, I actually have to heal now because of it.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh, that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Please heal.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to attack, but it wouldn't let me earlier.
Alright.
There we go.
Where did he go?
Ha ha ha ha!
Really?
Alright, there we go.
Wow!
How do I jump that?
I jumped!
It told me to jump!
Holy shit.
shit god that level is hard all right chain i don't think i
actually i'm gonna go with decode freeze and he that guy is
so difficult holy fuck all right instead of
we gotta get the charge piercer all right we're gonna do one
more run on that i I don't think we need the red area
anyway, the red room.
I'll do one more run.
Holy shit.
Oh.
Okay, I do have a, I have enough for a hack too for her.
Oh my God, that's cause of that area.
There you go.
Enter.
all right
it's just this red room it's like the ship is so tanky so
it's like even harder because of it oh my god grab the decoy
gun oh my god that's not the gun I want it that sucks that
was definitely not the gun I wanted to grab now it's my turn
there you go
all right what the fuck oh my god I'm like trying to I'm so
mad all
right where is he get him Are you fucking kidding me?
That's it.
Oh
You fucker
Actual fucker Get
the hack get the hack in
That's right get out of here
Oh, that's not a lot of damage oh my
god yes oh my god oh the photon gave it clutch oh thank god
all right the impact in the photon came in clutch there oh
the double lumen pure lumen i just started beaming
Oh, I beamed him.
All right, that's good that he got sunlocked too.
Thank God for that.
Thank God for the sunlocked.
That's too many purple stuff.
Oh, that's a lot of purple stuff.
That is a lot.
Oh my god, it doesn't travel across.
It doesn't get...
Unfortunately...
Oh!
Boom, there we go.
Alright, we're gonna grab that here just in case.
Just in case.
Wait, what?
Alright, that's fine.
It's too busy right now.
Alright.
Oh yeah, I didn't need a heal as well.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
The decoy gun actually came and clutched the stab.
Alright, I got rid of that.
Wherever that leads to.
I don't even know what I turned off.
I just saw a room.
Wait, actually, is it a fake?
There's a...
fake room here i knew it i was like there's items in here i
came i finally got the notice grabbing me level six access
oh my gosh you got promotion at work transfer to
experimental pragmatics in other words dr higgins lab that's
fine and danny but a notice also documented all my hidden
rooms and hollow walls was this their way of telling me to
cut it out doesn't say that outright if i heard the new
management ai they're rolling out will require a biolink for
every staff member Guess my fun with the hollow walls is
coming to an end.
Oh, this is making me wonder.
Am I being watched right now?
Out of way, I've got a week to reply to transfer notice.
Should I go for it?
You should go for it, Shannon.
Who cares if they're always watching you?
All right, water guns.
That's dangerous.
You knew in your heart that they were watching you.
But look at that.
You got promotion, though.
It was all worth it in the end.
Tell me you got something.
I think it's a mod.
Might be good to have.
It's like something here.
I can't see shit.
It's so dark.
Oh, I don't like that.
Wait, is that the right way to go?
Because there is, like, a parkour area here.
So I don't know.
A double check.
Oh, yeah.
That's where I'm sitting.
supposed to go.
So this is just bonus.
Okay, what's over here?
Oh, there's gonna be enemies here, isn't it?
What is down here?
Oh, they want me to print stuff.
It's never a good time.
They want me to print stuff.
Oh, I'll get that for the riot blaster.
Alright, into the scary basement I go.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Alright,
I can't see shit right now, so give me a sec!
Oh my god.
Okay, I need to heal.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh, I forgot about the other Got it, guys.
There we go.
Cool.
Got one more Stasis Net.
Decoy gun.
We're putting it all out there.
Oh, you're like this.
Oh, wait, there is a gun next to me.
All right, we got another photon laser.
Oh.
Stop hiding!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
Alright, there we go.
I can't believe it.
It kept hiding in the trees!
And it was working!
Oh, that's all I get.
God, that better be a good-ass node.
It's really it.
I went to a creepy basement for that.
My god!
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
It's alright.
I can heal.
Holy shit.
It was right behind me.
he wasn't here I was not expecting that at all the fucking
plank
all right back here all right here we go grab the box yay
double upgrade that's enough to upgrade her I'm pretty sure
I thought they were on a vacation.
Wait, what do you mean?
I thought you said they were all on vacation.
They're on the cruise right now, right?
They're on a work retreat, guys, right?
Surely they're just on a retreat.
Fucking knew it.
That's right.
Boom!
Oh.
Let's grab this guy out of here.
The laser's not gonna get me, right?
Alright.
Charging flesh!
His laser is warming up!
Okay, what?
Here they come again!
Right on!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to grab the shotgun.
But it wouldn't let me just now.
Oh, it was full.
It was locked up.
The work retreat to the five.
I'm just kill it here right now.
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm giving you a sec right now.
There we go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh my god.
Oh, not this guy.
Wow.
Amazing.
All right.
It's okay.
We have this.
Okay, they're all gone.
Oh my god, he was right there.
All right.
That's one core down.
Keep it up, you.
How you like this?
That's right.
How you like that?
Okay.
There we go.
I think that's it.
That should be all over.
Oh, thank God.
He kept the hack.
Oh, there he is.
Whoops.
I forgot about you.
I thought I forgot you went invisible there.
What the fuck?
He was like, oh, she won't see me.
Let me just go invisible real quick.
He was right.
I didn't even notice him
There we are A bunch of guns now
Oh there it is
Okay that's glass I just gotta make sure I had to make sure
If that was glass or not I can't trust them windows
All right.
Windows, they could be anywhere, you know?
Could be you.
It could be me.
The way forward should be clear.
Okay, oh, we gotta go this way.
Twizz, oh wait, we already got that.
We, yeah, we should head back.
We got refill.
We got refill right now.
I can't believe they'd eat us attack all the people at the
cradle.
Triller's a survivor.
Here's a water gun.
You might be depressed right now, but don't worry.
We can fix that with retail therapy.
It's time for me to shine.
You gonna play with it?
You're just gonna go back.
Alright, you're just gonna go back.
Okay, sure.
Worked so hard on that one.
You're just gonna go back right back to there.
Um, what do I want to upgrade?
Oh yeah, I want to upgrade the...
I don't know what to upgrade, chat.
We'll get the Charge Piercer, because it has Keem and
Clutch, and the Shockwave Gun.
All of those have Keem and Clutch for me.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know.
Maybe expo...
No.
I'll see you.
save up for the next one.
I should have enough now for it.
Yeah, I do.
Alright, she's mega hacking now.
Now she's strong.
Kirsten, that is double charge.
Ooh, that's true.
Yeah, double charge.
I think I should save it, because I want to upgrade the
shock wave gun or the photon laser.
So I'm going to save for that.
Alright, bingo time!
new training sim data has arrived until next we meet i still
need a bingo new training sim data has arrived be sure to
give it a try all right nice that we actually need that
another cartridge over there we are honored to provide one
of our greatest goods um can't really do anything i'll grab
this so i can grab a bingo here and a here for a triple
bingo all right let's go eight uh let's go seven or diana is
this oh yeah we are why we need as much hp as we can get
yeah no drone packing heat freeze
I suppose?
All right, let's try that.
Oh!
All right, off we go.
We continue on.
All right.
Oh, that's a lot of...
Man, why are there items below us down there?
Show the...
Oh, man.
I wonder if this is a red room.
Hmm.
Surely that's not a red room right below me or anything.
Seems like a lot of people down there.
More terminals.
No way.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
I actually can't see.
There's so many people!
Oh my god, please.
What is going on right now?
Oh god.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, we'll just do that.
Oh,
I'm trying.
Alright, nice, critical.
I'm doing okay.
I'm just running around hoping things die.
I'm just trying my best.
Oh, oh.
Leave the shooting to me.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's no longer okay.
It is no longer okay.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
There is so many things on my screen right now.
There really is a lot of things.
All right, boom.
Oh, man, I really could have used that multi earlier.
So awkward.
Pretty awkward, not gonna lie.
There we go.
There you go.
Everybody's linked now.
Oh, my god, I can't dash anymore.
Wait, I'm less.
Oh, my god.
There's more.
There is no way.
There is no way there's more.
Check.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
We're charging.
I'm charging.
That's good.
Oh, I'm trying my best not to.
Diana, do not worry.
It's not intentional.
Diana please I'm trying not to I swear to God it's not
intentional okay there you go oh last one I saved the big
boy for last there
you go there you go
boom all right And another one.
Oh my god, how many times that guy hacked you?
Oh, we did it.
That one was a lot easier than the last red room.
I will say.
That's a lot of money, too.
Here.
Here you go.
Eat some ram.
After hard, you deserve a little snacky.
Alright, nice.
All right, she got a little ram snacky through all the
fucking stress from that.
I will have to rep- I gotta print my guns again.
All right, is that everything?
All right, I gotta go back and print more guns.
I ran out of guns there.
Yeah.
Turn the shoulder.
All right.
Gun print time.
It'll be fun.
I have so much experience now.
That's right.
And I'm going to live till I'm 90.
Right?
Diana?
That's right.
We're both going to to live a long, healthy life.
Nothing's gonna stop us.
Alright, let's grab the shockwave gun.
Okay.
That was the last loadout.
I finally remembered to do that.
I only took the end game.
At end game, I finally realized R equals use last loadout.
I saw someone mention that earlier and I was like oh, yeah,
and then I proceed to forget
Okay I have to go left side, but I want to go right for loot
You've got to be kidding me wait There should be some
terminals nearby Wait, where am I supposed to go
Look out do you get close?
Oh wait.
Yeah, I'm just gonna kill him.
Oh, nice.
Oh, well I used all of it.
Haha!
Get dodged!
Yeah, saving it for pragmatic too.
Just like how I like it.
Actually...
What the fuck?
How is he still alive?
There we go.
Holy shit, that guy tanks so much.
I thought he had his core open.
I guess not.
At least I gotta, like, exchange my gun.
I can't get through there.
Oh.
Oh, I thought that was like door locked or something.
Gotta go this way.
Oh, fuck.
That's where I was supposed to go.
Oh, god damn it.
See, it's okay.
He's not bleeding.
Oh, no.
This black stuff is all that's left.
Wait, what?
He didn't.
disintegrated what hey Diana think you can cleanse infected
humans oh no once their cells get eaten away no not John
Pergamata I see there's nothing you can do oh shit
They're dead, dead.
Oh my god, they got eaten away by the filament.
That's right.
Be careful what you 3D print, guys.
We're gonna get you.
Yeah, I feel like we're supposed to go...
Yeah, we were supposed to go up, but...
Ooh.
money you might 3d print your last print guys all right
better go this way i haven't used any yeah i don't need a 3d
print any guns right now as you know daisy higgins higgins
dr higgins daughter has passed away the truth is her death
was not caused by illness the higgins have been running a
clinical trial on a lumen film compound using pragmata and
the outcomes were more than encouraging, so he reported his
findings to Earth HQ.
Then, one of the higher-ups at Delphi attended a claim
credit and pushed... Oh, no.
Age, sex, and the compound was administered.
However, Pregnata could not perfectly replicate human
physiology.
The formula remained unstable and was far from ready for
human use.
Dr. Higgins issued repeated warnings, but no one You're
supposed to insert it on mice!
That's what animal testing is for!
After the injection, it was Daisy, Dr. Higgins' daughter,
signs all witnesses to bury the truth.
This is clearly corporate murder, a preventable tragedy.
I only recently heard this story from a first-hand source.
Well confirmed, it's probably true.
Oh, no.
Just skip the rat trials.
This is why we have rats.
Disgusting.
Oh, my God.
There were people behind me, too.
There you go.
All right.
That's one core down.
Keep it up, you.
Be careful.
This is my turn.
All right, one more.
Oh, God, there's so many.
Oh, fuck.
God damn, the goddamn stupid lasers.
Oh, I fucked it up.
But it's okay, I have a critical here.
Oh, my God, the goddamn stupid laser.
John, take this.
All right.
So were they pretending to be her and yelling him to make
him she was i think she died after joki no no no come on
come on no no no no no no no you already ate you ate you ate
you ate no no you already ate at like five hours ago so you
have to eat right now
I ain't come in.
I ain't let you in.
You can come in.
That's it.
Let him fight the mob.
He would eat it.
He has eaten a bug before.
Oh, fuck.
It's gotta be close.
I gave him a treat today, guys.
Don't want to keep her waiting, right?
No more treats right now.
Here he got...
Here he got a treat.
all right he walked away I let him inside yes Ian I don't
know what it was but I saw him oh he ate a spider I saw him
I was like look at this look at that spider and he's like oh
okay well he looked at it
he did what he was told to do
I don't even know if I'm supposed to run back
let's see oh i oh i can go this way
all right let's grab this oh whoops i got cocky there oh i
got cocky again
all right holy shit what the fuck where did you come from
he just zoomed over Yeah, some yummy protein for him.
That makes two.
And three more hiding somewhere.
Yeah, there's one over there.
Nice.
Whoa!
Alright, goodbye.
Wait, what?
What's that?
Oh, wait, I did not see this guy.
I was like, what's that flashing over there?
Surely it's not an enemy.
Walker?
Oh, the one I was just fighting.
Oh no, that guy!
Okay.
Oh!
Let's just use that.
Just a little...
It's alright, just a little pinch.
There's something up here?
I knew it.
I was like, why would they put that there?
You're sure the last one's in here?
It is?
Okay, we're missing one more somewhere.
Where's the last one?
Oh, there it is.
God, it's always above me.
Every time.
What?
Yeah, it took more time than I'd like, though.
Just a little purple doesn't hurt nobody.
I already have that.
Oh, castle.
I saw 20% left.
Oh, shockwave's good.
Okay, we'll grab.
Yeah, grab that.
That's only has two bullets left.
All right, drone time.
Boop.
All right, I'm ready.
We're coming out.
Uh...
Boop.
All right, and then I'll grab rid of him too.
All right.
Just get rid of this guy too.
Boom!
There we go.
Step off.
Nice.
There's another one.
Boop!
That's right.
Kick the ends!
Take a shower, buddy!
I'm gonna break that.
Oh my god, one hit!
Let's fucking go!
Alright.
Easy!
My drone is doing the heavy lifting right now.
Thank god.
Oh, is that it?
Missile spotted.
God fucking damn, it's never it.
It's never it.
There is no way.
There's no way.
He actually sidestepped on me.
That's crazy.
He actually was like, yeah, that's right.
charging.
Oh, we'll be ashamed if I move to the left.
Get them out.
Get you.
God damn me.
I fucking got me.
Fucking move to the left.
Fuck yeah.
I'm returning.
I got repaid.
print stuff.
It had ultra.
It's like, hmm.
I wonder why that lady is standing still and charging.
Is she trying to charge your gun?
It would be a shame if I just moved to the left.
Two hops this time.
Okay.
We'll go out of the...
I have more capacity.
I don't think I need that.
We'll grab the photon laser, actually.
And then I should have enough for...
I got the heat.
I think that was the most important one for me.
Oh, we'll grab a photon lasers then.
Alright, it's time to build a sandcastle, Diana.
Where did she go?
I can't believe Daisy died.
That's right, I have a sandcastle.
I can't believe she died.
Dad, look, I got you a sand castle.
Look at that.
No sand.
See, that's how you do it.
Oh, your dog died.
Look, look, Dad, I got you a...
I got you an iPad.
Yay!
Oh my god, I finished it.
It's the first time I finished the full set.
Cheer up.
Have a sand castle.
I get distracted.
Dad of the year.
Guess what, kiddo?
I got you something special!
Daisy, who?
Parent of the year.
Distract every traumatic memory with gifts.
My dad did that.
He'd be like, I'm sorry, here, have a new laptop.
I do want a new laptop!
Sorry that happened.
Anyway, remember that laptop you really wanted?
Do you want me to get it to you right now?
It's the act of baking.
That's fine.
And I turned out just fine.
Not everything needs to be fun.
Too real.
Cheaper than there.
All right.
Oh, what?
What is it?
Oh, it's a lot.
It's target practice, The whole point is to make a mess.
That's what makes it so fun.
Don't hold back.
Drench the place.
Go big or go home.
Oh, and just so you know, water guns on Earth are typically
used outside.
So getting everything all soaked is no problem.
Oh, that makes sense.
Alright.
New training sim data.
have more oh you stamped be sure to give it a try almost
close to bingo bingo all right and then triple bingo
apparently this gun is good okay i should know apparently i
actually don't know
what is this is this gun even good That deploys mines that
can be fused.
Oh no, no, fuck that shit.
No, I'm not even gonna learn that.
I'm gonna fuck that.
I'm gonna mine myself.
Fuck that shit.
I'm not even gonna bother trying to learn it.
The mine gun is broke.
Yeah, but I'm gonna fuck it up every time.
You know it, guys.
I'm gonna fuck up the mine gun.
It's the best gun in the game.
I'm gonna fuck I'm much okay I'll try it I'm gonna try it
once You know I'm gonna fuck it up guys Alright I'll go
upgrade it then I have the money for it might as well
But kabooy Kaboom though Alright let's see how this goes
chat
You know I'm gonna mess it up.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Best time to try out Kablui.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
Did I dodge it?
Kablui.
Oh my god, he actually hit me.
Be careful.
Oh my god, he kablooey me.
I can't be bothered.
Get this out of here.
Kablooey!
There we go.
Kablooey again!
Did it work?
Wait, did it work guys?
I can't stop.
Pack the world!
Oh, I could do this.
Kabooy!
There you go.
I should heal, actually.
What the heck they're trying to pull?
Oh my god, what is it trying to pull?
Oh my god, it's trying to pull me up.
I do not know what it did.
So maybe it's not cool.
bad get out of here oh nice we overheat it
what dodge get dodge
the oh did i ducked it i'm trying to hack oh
there you go
whoop that's right get dodge
BAM!
Wait, the mines was actually OP.
Look at that.
Easiest fucking boss fight of my life.
I just spammed 80 mines on there and just kept kablooing
him.
I don't even think... I think he had like 20 other moves,
but I was just like...
I just actually... I did a speedrun skip there.
20 moves, more like one.
So this is the loop.
Alright.
It's been 10 days since Dr. Higgins shut himself away in his
lab.
Is there no way to reach him?
Dr. Higgins is isolating himself to focus on his heavy
workload and is not available for communication.
Even the secretary's office has been unable to reach him.
Should he emerge from the lab, he may remain unapproachable
for some time.
So it's advised to follow him to allow him the necessary
space.
This document must remain stringent.
within the little filament lab secretaries office until dr.
Higgins provide further instructions Noah Parker a former
lab staffer staff member is unresponsive due to advancing
dead filament contamination and shows no reaction to
external stimuli furthermore a visual examination conducted
have completely lost original form due to and he is likely
to cease oh oh yeah um I mean that guy doesn't have his
right chest is gone.
Looks like Higgins had been out of contact for a while.
I think majority of those are, yeah, I assume so.
I assume like he's dead.
Like his entire, isn't your heart on the right side?
Yeah, likely to cease.
We don't know if there's still a heart there, but you know,
half of chest is gone.
Truly the heart will survive.
oh it's on the left oh yeah i guess because it didn't eat
the heart and they're like maybe he's alive oh his office
hours just maybe there's a possibility oh maybe he was so
consumed by grief he reprogrammed eight because and he's
like fuck the earth he took her from me oh he might have
reprogrammed him it was premature again It's just a lie.
Oh,
man.
His daughter died.
That's awful.
Poor doctor.
Whoops.
I keep accidentally replaying.
I'm sorry, Daisy.
I couldn't save you.
I wasn't there when you needed me the most.
your daddy is a complete fool same thing happened when your
mother passed experiment thinking i was the only one who
could save her i threw myself into the my work jesus that
could be genetic bro what do you mean wait there was another
page it was all my selfishness my arrogance no even so the
clinical pragmatic trials were going well we were so close
to seeing the light at the end of the tunnel why did it have
to end like this why did delphi choose you feel so empty now
daisy i should have stayed with you i should have never come
to the moon i warned them it was premature again and again i
was fooled to trust them that's fucked because it's like
shame on him like shame on them when the mom when his wife
passed but like now the second time that was his fault at
that point well not his fault that his daughter dad but like
my research was you should have been self a little bit
selfish you know you're already fucked up with the wife
dying oh oh someone else is gonna get a heart attack who
could it be back to work kiddo I guess we'll never know
we're gonna have a new mystery to solve
The doctor's dead?
Yeah.
Then he left his work to 8.
He wanted 8 to finish the job.
There is loot over there.
Where's the body?
I'm pretty sure it's a dead philip.
It's right here.
He's just a goo now.
The philip got him.
You literally turn into goo.
Dr. Higgins, I wish to express the deep loneliness I'm
experiencing as I can no longer speak with you, but worry
not, before your body failed you, our time together allowed
me to reconstruct your fragmented memories, to fully
understand you.
You're desperate to tell everyone about the true dangers of
dead filament.
You can make that happen by transforming the dead filament
itself into a memory medium and sending it to Earth as a
singular unified being.
Everyone, it touches come to understand your wish directly
dr hannah i will deliver your will to earth no matter the
costs wait so it's not bad
but like into a memory medium surely that that can't go
wrong it oh no it's 100 yeah i was gonna see that that's bad
right it is but why how what do you mean by transforming
into memory medium
like yeah oh she doesn't know it will actually kill everyone
okay yeah i was like i thought it was bad guys i think we
fucked up teaching the ai yeah i was gonna say oh she wants
to know how dangerous is oh better start preparing for the
war oh that's what it means I was just like why fuck are you
sending it down to earth I was like I don't think that's
what the doctor's final wish was eight guys we the AI might
not might with the AI learning program might have been
corrupted it's like what was it it's like there was like
when when people were corrupting grok oh yeah yeah guys
remember when grok was went really really bad that like elon
had to like like temporary disabled grok because people were
teaching it really bad things during its ai learning yeah
it's it's basically like that there that's her way into the
orbital elevator all right let's go I'm coming to stop you
eight.
They're like, we got a temporary disabled rock now.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I can't upgrade.
And like fed it misinformation.
I can do one more.
Oh my gosh, she's fully hackable now.
Change the world.
My final message.
Goodbye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I see.
I think you.
Thank you.
There it is.
Oh, where is?
What are you looking for?
Oh.
Oh, no.
Sand's all over the place.
I like how the sand feels on my toes.
I press down and sink in.
Yeah, it's because you're not wearing shoes right now,
Diana.
It's pretty nice since you're barefoot.
Yeah, exactly.
The sand's clean and soft, but some beaches are loaded with
rocks.
We'll make sure to get you some water shoes before we head
to the beach.
Okay, they'll probably need some regular ones too.
And socks.
I don't really get it, but whatever you say.
He's just like, I like the feeling.
He's like, okay, I still like the sand.
On Houseward of Common Man, make corporate pull.
The good old days when you can make AI.
Very, very racist.
And they're like, oh, fuck.
Wait a minute.
Oh, you have quite the aisle.
Thank you for your patronage.
Or that one time, I said this example before.
But that one time where I think it was like a accounting
company used AI to check the books or something.
And then it made up random numbers.
It made up random numbers because they all they want to do
is like be good at its job So they're like we'll just make
all these random num and be like and have be like I don't
remember which company it was but it was basically an AI
making up random numbers And then one guy finally decided to
double check its work And they're like wait a minute none of
these numbers make sense.
Why did they keep give like?
Yeah, why did it why did it keep saying that?
It just, yeah.
You're like, you wanted to see this, so I had to lie.
And then he was like, and he was like, I now have to
re-check everything, because it's been doing this for six
months.
Oh.
Uh.
I hear him.
But where?
you hear that he's singing to us
there's an upgrade here too what the fuck it like pushed me
back for some reason oh i have to go this way i was talking
about that with my co-workers the failure accounting i said
i missed the stream but i'll catch up i have a good stream
also second time we just lost our entire money due to ai oh
my uh do you need like a human person to do like the checks
and balances of the AI's work but then that requires them to
pay more money thank you for the super chat music thank you
thank you
I hear him singing to me he's like uh uh did
you hear about the AI that's used to debug and end up
deleting everything oh I heard about that one too a mr.
broken body in the super chat thank you thank you yeah I
heard about that AI as well
Did you hear about that AI program where they try to make it
play Minecraft and then it drowned itself?
I don't remember which one it was.
They're trying to make it do something specific in Minecraft
and then it went into the water and then drowned itself.
I was like, that's crazy.
He did not want to, he did not fuck with that.
All right.
Yo, was that Nero?
I thought that one was funny.
And then it was like, fuck this.
Alright.
Nah, bro.
Fuck this game.
Pick him up a mad close by.
Any idea what it does?
Come on.
We'll know when we get there.
barrier oh I'm just gonna send I don't know this gives me
extra money anyway I'm gonna do that real quick oh hello
little goop so I see oh shit all right that's fine are they
expecting to get closer from where
Oh, it's hiding, aren't you?
You're hiding.
Oh, I see you.
I have this coin here.
There you go.
That's right.
You thought you could hide from me?
Boom!
Oh, man.
90%.
Hurry, Hugh.
I'm on it.
Reza, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know someone made an AI.
Uh, like a...
Oh, what the fuck?
The cat one, we're like...
Which one was... It was a lot of time ago, but...
I remember someone made an AI of that...
The cat...
The cat character, because it just needs to stick to you.
Alright, there you are.
Oh my god, you get a little flip.
Alright, easy.
Don't worry.
I have plenty of time for this.
But no gun I just realized.
Oh, no.
I might have used up all my guns.
Uh.
I mean.
Alright, let's just.
Alright, let's grab and hit this.
No Kablu.
We gotta save Kablui.
But I might save Kablui for this.
Oh, kibblee again?
Kibblee?
Surely it's gonna...
Kibblee!
Right?
Surely!
Alright.
Nice.
Kibbleeed one of them.
Jormor?
Says there's more lockdowns somewhere.
Oh, there it is.
wait wait it's kablooey time all right there you go more
kablooey more kablooey oh shit more kablooey
all right oh fuck what the fuck is that
all right i'm gonna
oh no oh no there's too many things It's on my screen.
It's fine.
Oh, yeah?
I'll stop it right now.
Oh, shit.
All right.
It's fine.
It's the last thing I'll do.
Am I in the circle?
I can't tell.
Oh.
Is that it?
Oh, I forgot about my drone.
That could have been a lot easier.
I could have made that a lot easier for myself.
All right, no more lockdown.
Wait, there's more?
Oh my god, what do you mean there's more?
I- What do you- wait a minute?
What do you- Oh, that's when you know it's end game.
Okay, there is stuff up there though.
I was like, excuse me.
Hey, what do you mean?
There's more.
I thought I did the thing.
I do have my drone.
How do I get up there though?
I just fly?
What the fuck?
How do I get up there?
How do I need like infinite dashes?
I might stop needing infinite dashes or some shit.
I'll put my drone out just in case.
Alright.
Oh, fuck, you know what?
No, fuck this.
But Dad is like, yeah, fuck this, I tell you.
He's like, you're right.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, no!
No!
I'm gonna give him a little food.
I'll be back.
He's just going.
I don't want to get in trouble.
Alright.
I'm back.
I didn't want to I don't get into trouble so I gave him a
little bit of food oh shit okay maybe I shouldn't have used
my hack on just these guys maybe that could have been a bad
idea all
right I just need to get rid of him
poop oh nice
Easy.
All right, we just have one more bullet left on for ammo for
our drones, but surely there's no more after this, right?
Oh, that's the tram.
Went to go up.
Oh, upgrade.
You know how eight's trying to send that bomb into Earth,
right?
Do you really think that's what the doctor wanted?
I mean, he didn't want to, you know, he was really mad about
what happened.
What's your best guess?
I think I wouldn't want all this.
That's how you feel.
Well, the doctor she knew was still a lot, like, her, his
daughter was still alive.
Not consumed by the grief of his dead wife and his dead
daughter.
Should we take a break?
That's two different doctors.
I mean, he is...
He's like, if I'm dying, I'm going to take them all down
with me.
Alright, we're going to return to shelter, restock all our
stuff, reprint everything.
Yeah, he had nothing left to lose.
And the 8 was like, that's right!
He has nothing left to lose.
Like, fucker!
okay this might be the final showdown this looks very
finally all right let's go let's go all in all in on the
mines you i i was really sad when i found out what happened
to the doctor hey that's all right still i don't feel like
eight does that because i'm not as good as she is what no
that's not it you're perfect diana why are different eight
literally saw her dad died in front of her so let's move on
okay it is going through trauma right now you not yet don't
worry it'll happen soon don't worry if we know what what's
gonna don't worry with the ray it's going it's gonna happen
soon and then you'll know how I'll 8 feet of...
Don't keep these...
Some might say very soon.
Music, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I came back to mention one more thing.
Um...
I bought this game because I saw you playing it.
And I've been in the DLC and I'm doing my lunatic run right
now.
Oh my god.
Good luck music name is super chat Thank you.
Thank you Yeah after the upgrades things started dying.
I started having more fun again I guess I was like really
behind upgrade rise.
I had to do the trials more I was like, oh my god things are
dying now.
They're not bullet sponges anymore
So how's the packing coming?
splendid thanks to you the shipment for earth is almost
ready yeah that's like some calm ass music for what she's
gonna commit genocide the purpose we were meant to share
oh shit i
decide my own way and i'm going to earth with you you still
don't understand You are pragmatic.
So what?
She's more than that.
She's real to me!
And she's not something for you to use and throw away!
You're beyond repair.
Oh.
This is where we partner.
ways for good oh
my god guys maybe we should not print in new york city guys
we might have fucked up
guys we made a mistake trying to print new york city we
might have lived too many dead filament
oh my god what the fuck she grew up holy shit she just she
just speedrun puberty see this is what they don't teach you
in sex ed when there's two holy fuck oh my god
All right.
Okay, but what if I...
Oh, hack the world!
Oh shit, that's not good.
That is not good.
I'm trying to hack the world right now.
oh my god this
cat she's pretty strong not gonna lie
what the fuck oh i don't think it's cleansing anything not
gonna lie can't move you can track two
all right
all right where i should oh my god
okay i need to use more it's okay he's distracted
holy are you kidding me
Jesus The hacking is so slow Oh my god The goddamn dive
I'm trying
There we go
Where the fuck is it Oh He's trying Oh, dodge.
There you go.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I have to cleanse it.
Over heat.
Oh, not again.
Oh, fuck.
It's so fast.
Okay.
Can't.
Counter-hacked.
Cleans!
Oh, that's not enough.
That is absolutely not enough.
Are you serious?
Keep cleansing!
Oh, I do not have HP left.
Are you...
The double!
The goddamn double!
Whoa!
Guys, I think I'm fucked.
I keep forgetting the cleanse.
Most likely, guys, this ain't looking so good.
No more second guessing, guys.
Just do it.
Oh, never mind.
Hugh!
Okay.
Alright, now that I know, I keep forgetting the cleanser.
You okay?
The second hit fucks me up, man.
That second hit is rough.
Alright.
I think we know the fight now.
We know how to do the fight.
I Think it's possible Whoops It keeps throwing all that
stuff at us Doing okay I'm hanging in there, but all those
dead filament spikes are throwing me off Alright I can try
to cleanse them You still have no We'll stop you no matter
what That's right I believe in the power a friend so shit
there we go oh that's awkward for me boom
god damn it
there you go
yep get
hacked get hacked oh shit oh
shit oops all right it's time to get extra hacked whoops
boom
all right I got a heal now
There we go.
Hack the world!
Oh god.
Keep doing it!
Okay.
Now we're cooking!
Now we're cooking with Pragmata!
There you go.
Boom!
Oh, watch this!
Bonus hack!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god, that's right, critical!
It's a full course meteor right now!
We're almost there!
Where is he doing?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What the fuck is he doing?
Okay, okay, we're in so loud.
Oh my, no, no.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
I'm trying.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
We just made it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Oh!
No, no, no!
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad for me.
Oh god.
No!
Come on.
My god, that was so...
That was so close!
X!
Diana!
I knew she was cleansed, but I was scared.
I was scared.
I wanted to see I could stun her a little bit before I hack.
I was panicking.
So you went.
We did it, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh.
We can reprint you.
Where's your memory stored?
Where's your backup?
Transport's at the top of the tower.
Oh, we had to stop it still.
We got to stop the thing.
No time to grieve.
No time to process that we killed a child.
I gotta go.
Mission success.
Oh, it's not over.
What do you mean?
That's not the final boss.
I was getting ready to do time.
Like, it's speedrun.
Oh, no.
It's not an elevator.
Diana.
Oh, no.
You okay?
It's like that Kingdom Hearts shit with Oogie Boogie comes
out as a blob.
At least we got to talk.
I'm sorry.
I know it's hard but we can't slow down there should be a
transport for us at the top and go to earth oh
everything's okay Diana everything's alright just got a
tummy ache I eat bad seafood what I'm gonna do we gotta see
the ocean right or you want to do some bird watching I want
to do both.
That's a spirit.
Let's go, kiddo.
Oh.
Why do you decide to take me with you?
Then a moon sushi.
Shouldn't have tried to eat sushi.
That might have been expired on the moon.
Oh.
Oh, no.
All right.
Whose idea was to print New York City?
but without eight wait what it's out of control we can't
leave it like this it can follow us to earth
it's time jesus christ oh my god i was a lot like you a
thirst for life and all its mysteries big ass gun boy i had
a few bumps along the way but i had someone someone looking
out for me and now it's your turn a whole new life if you're
ready okay then let's go together i wouldn't be a capcom
game we'll fight you john asla that is true i was a little
disappointed in the end like for requiem because you know
how he's like turning reptile like the the monster like
what's his name the doctor like obviously The virus was
doing something reptile-y to him.
And then, in the end, he just turned into a John-ass blob.
Oh, shit.
I'm waiting.
I'll charge it up, Q.
You get rid of the ship.
Are we ready yet?
It's a very long way.
All right, reloading.
Boom!
That's right, say goodbye to your arm.
Alright, I'm ready to hack again.
That we are so...
How fucking far up are we?
Okay.
Here it goes!
I'm charging!
All right, I got him!
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, that was close.
That was so close.
Nice shot!
This isn't over yet.
The infinite uppies.
What the fuck is it doing?
Diana, are you okay?
Yeah!
Let's cut through it!
Protect us!
Give me a barrier!
Oh my god, we're... Oh, it's right here.
Oh, we're so cool.
Good-ass father's daughter bonding time.
Oh no.
Alright, now we only have one big-ass gun.
It's okay, it's okay.
One is all we need.
okay where do we aim where do we aim where do we aim diana
is it the head time all right it's the arm has to be the arm
there we go got it
jesus christ how many shots does it take when do we fucking
shoot the head Whoop, there goes the fiber internet.
Getting close to the shuttle.
This isn't good.
Let me try something.
What?
Where am I?
Okay, alright.
That's a lot.
Okay.
It's a lot easier.
Alright.
I was like, where am I in this?
Shut up No, how am I gonna get back?
No
Maybe this will work huh?
Oh, I what?
Not like this?
Oh Let me try just do a firmware upgrade a new upgrade came
out I guess we're walking home Holy shit Excuse me?
Here we go!
Oh yeah, why did I use the big mode earlier?
Oh my god.
Fucking cinema.
That should do it.
Oh?
Diana?
Oh no.
Does anyone have a battery pack?
Yeah, I should have read the manual next time.
She used to have too much energy.
Quick, I need to find an outlet stat.
I need to plug her in.
God damn it, Diana.
Don't scare me like that.
Yeah, how are we gonna...
No!
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me I have to do this again Oh my god
Please don't tell me I have to do this again Oh please don't
tell me I have to Please Alright guys You know the drill You
know the drill There's no way There's no way What does space
do Oh All right.
Oh, my guy.
I'll fight the final boss three more times.
Oh, we were so close.
We were so close to him.
No, don't, don't, no.
All right.
Here we go again, guys.
Here.
we go again what where is it where did it last leave oh
thank god oh thank god okay there's just too many debris
wait i can't even okay i have the fatal d3 okay fatal d3 d
error guys what is this
Oh, no.
Oh, no, please.
I just want to complete Diana's story.
Fatal.
Alright.
I keep getting.
It can happen.
Continue to follow.
Been having the same issue.
Oh, it's a driver update.
Alright.
it's related to driver updates all right try forcing dx guys
guys like i still if i do a driver update i still need to
restart i still
who would have thought don't i need to restart my drivers
like i mean restart my pc
to install because that's the yeah all right what driver
should we get guys all right usually don't update the most
recent drivers but like which one which driver is the best
suited all right previously installed oh oh has it really
been that long
Oh, wow.
Okay, you know when I say six months?
It might have been longer.
It may or may not have been longer than six months.
There was a driver update.
We get the newest one?
How long?
Do we get the...
2025.
Or, whoa, I'll never tell.
All right, I'm installing.
I'm installing the new drivers now.
I'm installing the one from yesterday.
Which might not be the most ideal.
But
we'll see how this goes.
Install.
Maybe if we're lucky, it won't make me restart.
All right, express installation.
Oh, hey, look, there's Progmata.
I gave me Progmata.
All right, installing drivers.
Because last time my driver updated was 2025.
A lie.
It won't let me beat the game until I install it.
All right.
Here we go.
We gotta wait now.
We were so close to the finish line too.
We were right there.
We were actually right there.
is there we almost made it we really did
all right here we go
the driver is holding me it's because like i i always get
you know like drivers you normally don't upgrade update uh
you normally don't update right away only because like
there's always like there's always something wrong so then
i'm always super paranoid about updating my drivers because
all right
hello i'm back all right let's see if this works guys i'm
back all right hello okay let's try this again let's okay
but before we try let's just try pragmata and see if we get
through i did not restart my pc it did not tell me to start
my pc for some reason so i take those guys i take the little
victories in life and this is one of them no compiling
shaders all over again
all right here we go we gotta compile all our shaders
it's small things in life
all right
it's all right we just got to get past that one area it
saved last time so it just needs to bypass that one section
all right we just gotta bypass that one area we just gotta
let it load wow look at all that beautiful debris are you
okay oh i made a promise right oh hold hold guys man i
wonder how many problems i could have solved i just updated
my drivers the world will never know though it worked it
actually worked i guess we'll never know guys how many
problems we could have solved if I just updated my driver at
least nine months ago will never know.
It will forever be a mystery.
That's so cute.
It will forever be the world's greatest mystery.
Well...
Don't worry, I'm back.
There we go.
I'm back again.
Very mean, dear.
It is one of, like I said, it's one of the world's greatest
mystery.
We'll never know.
Wonder how much we could have avoided.
Once we're back on earth, you can walk for yourself.
Hey, I can walk.
You sure?
I do it all the time.
Here, look.
Oh my gosh, you can finally walk now.
You'll be back on me in no time.
It was one of the world's greatest mysteries out there.
Never mind me forever, you know.
No, no, I'm slowly dying now.
I believe brute force to spy if we want it to.
Surely.
Honestly, I would not, I believe it.
Aww.
There's a cargo ship!
Oh my
god.
Can we go to Earth in that?
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I just pulled this off.
We're gonna do it, Diana.
We're gonna both go to Earth together.
That's right, you and me.
Is this how we're going to Earth?
Yeah.
That's right, thank God you don't know how to read.
tight fit but that'll do what about you explosions messed
everything up full automation is not an option gotta push it
to the end of the rail hang tight don't worry i'll be right
behind you there's another ship behind you diana and i'll
definitely be in there see
that ship behind you diana i'm gonna be in that ship
yeah it's a heavy bugger i want to help stay put it's too
risky
let me hack it no need just gotta give it a bit of the old
elbow grease
oh more energy
oh no he's gonna make it guys Look, he's looking at Earth
and thinking about all the fun things he's going to do with
his daughter.
Time to bring it in.
And all the class.
How are we going to get Pragmata too if he dies?
Be on Kennedy's sequels.
Bad news.
This is where we say goodbye.
Oh.
She can clean him.
Sorry, squirt.
I want to stay with you.
It's okay.
You're gonna be okay.
Oh.
Go find the scene.
Oh!
No, wait!
Oh, she has no, he has no oxygen now.
Have a safe journey.
oh now he drifts through he's gonna turn into black goop
i didn't know we're surprised that there's not even gonna be
a body
fun fact she's screaming dead
at the end but you can't hear because of the little oh you
finally called him dad i told you i told now she knows how
eight feels now she knows directly give the super chat thank
you thank you
i updated my drivers for nine minute for nine minutes of
gameplay left that's so fucked that's so like the game was
like that's too much shit you gotta update man we rendered
so many We render so many particles, Doki.
You have to update your drivers now.
And I was just like, are you fucking like...
That's crazy.
Like, yeah, we have to see it in this in HD.
You gotta see this man die in HD.
Look at it.
Oh, man.
How are we going to get Pragmata too?
If he's dead.
You got to keep him alive for two more sequels.
Yeah, I keep sending him the space.
They did it for Isaac.
They did it for Leon.
But they couldn't do it for you.
I didn't believe it
Oh I thought he was gonna live
This is not the true ending I'm not getting guys I feel like
the true ending is gonna be I'm gonna watch the true ending
guys You died so I could have a working driver I was
thinking drivers and estradiers are still overloading my
eyes I think it was super chat thank you thank you first of
all thanks for playing the game doki I'm a girl man I'm
crying my eyes out sorry thank you super chat thank you
thank you thank you in space no one can hear you cry no
one's gonna see his body out of there he's gonna be coop
chat thank you there is a secret ending that you only get
with doing the epilogue content well thank you the super
chat thank you thank you hey dokey i just joined the street
house he's alive very much alive he got he found this space
he found the ship and they flew back home and then they saw
the ocean oh you missed out man this he saw all of it he's
so very much alive all right let me see let me look up the
ending right now um alternate uh true ending pragmata oh
there's after credits all right let's see it youtubers ugly
crying at the end of pragmata whoa i'm sorry guys i'm maybe
like I have to update my drivers just to get this in.
Sorry.
Holy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This was the first stream I watched, and it could have been
better.
Congrats on finishing the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's gonna turn it.
He's gonna turn it to goof.
He's gonna...
He's gonna You're like Oh Damn I'm like He's gonna turn into
gold He's gonna
Keep I don't think I'm gonna be in that compilation Guys I
don't think I'm gonna make it into the compilation
See this is why I don't play the dog game I know I'm gonna
fucking ball my eyes out
i think it's just because i don't like kids i think i think
i just don't i think that might be it i don't you don't say
you don't say honestly valid Or maybe it's the up to the
driver update.
I hate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
Thanks for the perk mod shoes.
That was great.
You and Diana are adorable to get it.
Diana's very precious.
Congrats on finishing it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do not play that.
Yeah, no.
I just heard about the dog game.
I cannot handle that in general.
The kid's mom was so right.
I think I just have too many bad experiences with children
in general.
Give me back my tears.
You're a horrible woman.
And I'll thank you for the super chat.
I still felt bad.
I still, like, felt really sad.
like you died after all this time I thought I was gonna make
it it was just the fact that like I didn't cry I he died
more than here he died a great dad he did though Lolly thank
you the super chat thank you thank you oh she made it
the dog name it's where you like re the dog passes away and
he's in heaven he's trying to reunite with his owner it's
it's it i heard it's really really sad like i heard people
cry a lot for that one that one i will cry about oh wait she
found the beach what
i'm surprised is not is the government not surrounding her
right now you would think that like you know the government
airspace would detect a fucking ship crashing into the
ocean.
Like the satellite.
Oh wait, maybe we destroyed all the satellites.
Yeah, I was gonna say, the satellites did all explode on the
station.
She's ready.
She's ready to be our real kid now.
Congratulations.
You can now create completed game data.
Alright, save.
She's ready for the world.
The first one watched where I didn't cry.
Cry from the ending.
You're one of a guide, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat, Tako.
Thank you.
Look, maybe it's also because my game kept crashing, guys.
My game...
It could be that.
if i
all right we're just gonna watch the true ending i'm not
fucking that is holding around to the same image at the oh
that's cool engine image of the resident evil engine logo um
all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
all right true ending pragmatic gameplay all right True
ending and final boss.
Alright, I'm pulling you up.
We're just going to listen to it.
Where does it play?
Is it at the end?
Oh, it's at here.
Alright.
Alright, here it is.
Guys, hear it?
What's this?
Traveling alone today?
Oh, she's back!
Wait, was that it?
Oh!
She came back!
She came back to the ship.
No, no, it's just audio.
There's nothing to it.
Yeah, no, there's literally nothing, guys.
It's literally just audio.
It's a black screen, and it's like, welcome back.
You came alone today?
Or is that Hugh?
Oh, it's Hugh?
He made it.
Wait, he's alive!
I thought it was her, because it was from the moon, like,
from the moon, and then...
welcome back welcome back what's this traveling alone today
i thought it was just time passed i thought it was one of
those like because she put her hands up to the moon and i
was like oh and then it cuts to the dialogue i was like she
came back to the station i thought like you know it was like
10 years later and then she came back or some oh it's here
he lives see guys he's alive
He's alive, guys.
And then he died.
No, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure the printer is still working.
And then they figured it out.
They figured out how to...
They figured it out how to fucking print him a new heart.
Like, he worked again.
He got a new degree.
He got a microbiology degree on the fucking space shuttle.
Music.
Thank you.
Do you do the epilogue kind of yes.
Suit mod that's gripe that's suppressing.
so he but he lived because it stopped the growth thank you
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you thank
you yeah that's a true ending it's a blast hearing with
cabling welcome slowing back better be oh my god that means
he's alive he's fucking alive see guys i always that's why i
didn't cry i knew he was gonna live i knew they weren't
gonna kill him off he was gonna be the new leon kennedy chat
i was like there's no way they literally made a new ip and
they're not gonna milk it for sequels that's not the capcom
i know like i was like there's no way that's not the capcom
i know they would we never saw a body too we never saw the
body we saw i'm drifting away But that doesn't mean it's not
it's no one in the I knew I Knew they were gonna make a
sequel.
I knew he was gonna be alive That's why I didn't cry because
I believed I fucking believed so hard that he was still
gonna be alive That you guys doubted it you did not believe
in him that I did I That's why I didn't cry Because I knew
they were going to keep him alive so they can make prog mod
a two and three.
I knew he'd live.
That's crazy.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm the only one that didn't cry, guys.
I swear I'm not.
I swear I'm not a sociopath, chat.
I swear I can feel emotions.
I just believe that he would live.
I knew he was going to be alive.
I felt sadness.
Okay.
I did feel sad.
I was like, no, it's going to be goo.
Only how what I...
That's what a sociopath would do.
Gabe, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you
guys, I swear to God, I felt stuff, I did feel sadness
I like Diana I like her I just, I might not be, I might not
have any of it but you still like you got out thank you with
a super chat thank you thank you it's okay i didn't cry
either it's okay and you're also not a sociopath right i
just gotta be sure i just gotta be sure all right i i felt i
felt really sad but i also believed that he would live i
knew he was gonna tank that.
I was, I thought, I was like, I was like, there's no way.
There's no, it's Capcom.
They're gonna fucking make Pragmata too if this, this, if
this series works, guys.
And they are going to.
He's gonna come back.
He is their next Leon Candy.
They can't keep making, they can't keep milking Leon Candy,
guys.
He's gotta retire someday.
Look at him.
He's literally 50 now.
Leon they gotta rebuild him they gotta clone him and that's
why we got Hugh Hugh is our next Leon prodigy he is gonna
take the mantle yes they can but guys think about it what if
we have two Leon's we have Leon and Hugh we have a Delph and
and Leon we have different flavors of Leon we have Think
about that.
The greed of this woman.
Anyway, guys.
We did it.
We beat Pragmata, guys.
Oh, oh, right.
They give us super chat.
Thank you.
Well, Pragmata did sell a million copies in under two days.
So I'm pretty sure we're gonna get Pragmata too.
They give us super chat.
Oh, right.
Thank you.
Exactly.
and that's why they can't they wouldn't kill off you and i
believed in them anyway guys thank you all for coming to the
stream we think we be pragmatic i think we i think we okay
if it wasn't for all the game crashes and me for getting to
update my drive look i usually don't update my drivers until
i'm forced to and then these this is one of those cases
where i look it's i remember it's what was it night ring I
remember the last time I updated my drivers was for night
ring I remember now and I updated my drivers and then the
game kept crashing because like before I was lagging a
little bit when I was like doing like playing night ring so
now I was like you know I'm gonna go update when I was doing
a test run of night ring and I was like you know what I'm
gonna update my drivers before uh before the spawn the like
before the sponsor stream and so and it kept crashing so
that was like oh i have to down yeah uh and i was like okay
i gotta downgrade it because i don't like i like it the new
up the driver update kept crashing it so then i was just
like okay well and then i never touched my driver's since
yeah i until today until hey hey hey my driver pushed me all
the way till the end till the tram section all right it
surprisingly held up pretty it's always the trams guys it's
there was just so like the tram that led to to the outside
the space debris like anyway thank you all for watching that
was really fun as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up move around and get that blood flowing and if
you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it what
guys what a journey we had today me a perfectly normal
empathetic person that can feel sympathy and empathy um uh
we both had felt so many feelings in the end okay i need to
play Do I have to play the puppy game for you guys to show
you that I can cry?
Because we will not have fun with that.
I swear to God.
I will.
Oh my God.
We're not going to enjoy this, guys.
We all of us.
You and I will not enjoy this moment.
You cry.
He's, guys, I swear to God, I, I can't cry, I, all right,
all right, uh, anyway, anyway, I hope you guys all have a
great day, uh, and I'll see you guys tomorrow, whenever you
guys are free to watch me, and I thank you all for watching,
everybody, bye guys, bye!